bonjour bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver sur public sénat pour le
rendez-vous parlementaire phare de la
semaine les questions au gouvernement
elle commence dans une heure à 15 heures
précises
on va tout vous expliquer tout décrypter
avec cette semaine encore notre équipe
de journalistes et aujourd'hui nous
sommes avec dans l'hémicycle steve
jourdain un aperçu des thèmes ou plutôt
du thème qui se détache
oui bonjour tam c'est en quelque sorte
une spéciale co vivent aujourd'hui avec
bien évidemment cette question cette
question dans l'hypothèse d'un éventuel
reconfirme ans de plusieurs régions en
france et puis on parlera aussi de la
question des aides économiques débloqués
par le gouvernement ces aides sont elles
suffisantes
on verra ça tout à l'heure et aussi le
sujet qui emporte tout ou presque
aujourd'hui alexandre poussard et salle
des conférences pour toutes les
réactions à chaud des sénateurs et des
ministres qui allez-vous interviewé cet
après midi alexandre bonjour tam et bien
aujourd'hui on ne parlera pas que decaux
vite puisque on parlera également de
séparatisme islamistes et oui
aujourd'hui la commission des lois du
sénat examine le projet de loi du
gouvernement pour le respect des
principes républicains et je serai avec
dominique veryant la rapporteure du
texte pour la commission des lois du
sénat a tout à l'heure alexandre est
enfin notre streamer politique jean
m'assieds salut jean sur la plateforme
twitch du débat comme chaque semaine
avec ta communauté autour de cette
séance bien c'est bien spéciale chaque
semaine
hewitt hamon a hâte de voir avec avec le
chat sur twitch ce que vont poser comme
questions des sénateurs et sénatrices et
pourquoi pas des questions sur le
conseil de défense de ce matin par
exemple ça intéresse beaucoup de monde
par exemple dans une demi-heure notre
face à face la sénatrice les républiques
agnès canayer sera opposé à la sénatrice
communiste de la loire cécile cukierman
on parlera ensemble de la proposition de
loi sur la sécurité globale
le texte élaboré par les députés la
république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale était à l'origine de la crise
politique de l'automne rappelez-vous
depuis les esprits se sont bien apaisé
le sénat a largement réécrit les
articles les plus polémiques
on en débat à 14h30 mais d'abord la
situation sanitaire et des confinement
qui paraissent de plus en plus probable
nouveau conseil de défense sanitaire ce
matin gabriel atallah annonce à
l'instant que de nouvelles décisions
vont être prises en ile-de-france et
dans les hauts de france et puis le
premier ministre s'entretient cet après
midi avec les présidents des groupes
parlementaires
on va parler de toute cette situation
avec plusieurs invités avec olivier nau
sur ce plateau bonjour un jour vous êtes
sénateur uc du nord vous êtes membre de
la commission à des affaires sociales
avec nous également bruno megaman vous
êtes chef du service de réanimation de
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en vision avec
nos jean daniel lévy directeur délégué
de harris interactive ont pas à parler
avec vous de la façon dont les français
vont accueillir un peu toutes ces
nouvelles
et puis nous allons être rejoint tout à
l'heure avec xavier iacovelli snapper
r&d pays des hauts-de-seine est lui
aussi membre de la commission des
affaires sociales mais d'abord le point
sur la situation sanitaire hugo
lemonnier c'en est presque devenu une
habitude la france entre à nouveau dans
une semaine décisive avec au coeur des
préoccupations cette fois-ci l'île de
france avant même le traditionnel
conseil de défense sanitaire
le premier ministre annonce de nouvelles
restrictions pour 12 millions de
franciliens
initiation préoccupante et critique et
très clairement très clairement des
mesures du type de celles que nous avons
à utiliser auquel on a eu recours dans
les autres parties du territoire sont
très clairement sur la table ce soir
mais la maire de paris dénonce déjà le
manque de concertation de l'exécutif
avec les élus locaux
donc je n'ai absolument aucun élément
nous devions avoir une réunion hier avec
le préfet de police préfet de région ars
qui n'a pas été fait qui a été annulé et
reporté à demain et à ce stade aucun
appel ni même aucune information après
un confinement le week-end dans le pas
de calais sur la côte d'azur
ce serait donc au tour de l'île de
france le taux d'incidence y est
supérieure à 400 et on y dénombre autant
de passion réanimation qu'au sommet de
la deuxième vague en octobre dernier
si rien n'est fait la situation
continuera empirer prévient martin
hirsch on pense qu'on aura entre 1700 et
2000 100 patients à la fin du mois dans
13 jours
d'accord et si je mets une semaine de
plus c'est à dire si je vais au 6 avril
là on passe entre 2000 et 2008 100
patients en réanimation
c'est exactement la chose qu'on a eu du
mal à prendre en charge
il y a un an début avril de l'année
dernière signe d'une situation critique
tant sur le plan sanitaire que politique
le premier ministre réunit ce soir les
présidents de groupes parlementaires
la dernière fois c'était le 28 janvier à
la veille du discours d' emmanuel macron
qui à l'époque avait dit non au
confinement et on a appris aujourd'hui
que de nouvelles décisions vont être
prises elles ne concernent pas que
l'ile-de-france écouter gabriela talent
le porte parole du gouvernement
il a été décidé ce matin en conseil de
défense que des mesures supplémentaires
seraient prises dans un certain nombre
de territoires dans les prochaines
heures
des concertations seront amenés par
l'état avec les élus locaux dans les
régions île de france et au de france et
dans les départements qui
on continue à ces régions pour partager
l'état de la situation actuelle pour
recueillir l'avis des élus locaux sur
les différentes mesures qui sont
envisagées le premier ministre réunira
par ailleurs cet après-midi les comités
de liaison parlementaire à l'issue de ce
travail
le premier ministre avec le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé alan seront à
demain à 18 heures dans une conférence
de presse
les mesures qui seront retenus pour ces
territoires pour une application à
partir de ce week-end on sent donc
clairement que le tempo s'accélère
emmanuel macron visite cet après midi
l'hôpital de poissy dans les yvelines il
doit s'entretenir par visio notamment
avec des maires d'île de france bruno
megaman quand vous voyez la situation
actuelle en ile de france on va regarder
quelques chiffres le taux d'incidence et
au delà des 400 c'est la limite qui
avaient été définis dimanche par jean
castex pour re confiné on a 418,9 les
services de réanimation sont saturés
avec un taux d'occupation de 100 de 62%
et puis il ya cinq mille neuf cent sept
personnes hospitalisées
pensez vous qu'il faut pour confiner et
vitres confiné effectivement comme vous
le dites la situation épidémique est
mauvaise
malheureusement tous les chiffres sont
en augmentation
donc effectivement notamment au niveau
de la réanimation nous sommes sous
pression
nous n'avons plus de possibilité
d'accueillir de nouveaux patients donc
plus on attend et plus effectivement on
va se retrouver dans des difficultés il
faut savoir malgré tout qu'il faut
environ 15 jours entre la décrue des
contaminations et la décrue du nombre de
patients qui vont entrer en réanimation
donc effectivement si on ne fait rien
aujourd'hui on va avoir des difficultés
dans quinze jours à faire face monsieur
lire cela rappelait on pourrait se
retrouver dans une situation dans quinze
jours qui pourrait ressembler à ce qu'on
a connu en mars avril
effectivement là sans renforts venant de
l'extérieur sans déprogrammation quasi
totale des chirurgies non urgentes
on pourrait pas faire face et
effectivement je crois que et le
gouvernement l'a compris
il est temps effectivement désormais
malheureusement de prendre des mesures
de restriction plus importante pour
réduire les contaminations et pour vous
il faut re confiné toute la semaine ou
le week-end seulement ce qui a été fait
jusqu'ici dans les hauts de france dans
le nord pas de calais ou encore dans les
alpes-maritimes
alors d'un point de vue sanitaire pu
effectivement le confinement est stricte
et plus il a des chances de fonctionner
donc effectivement un confinement du
type de ce que l'on a connu en mars
avril serait le plus efficace malgré
tout bien sûr la décision sanitaire doit
aussi tenir compte de l'acceptabilité
par la population car décider de mesures
de restriction mais qui ne seraient pas
appliquées n'a aucun intérêt donc on a
vous dirais même au résultat paradoxal
d'entraîner une asphyxie de l'économie
de la vie sociale et à linverse de
poursuivre les contaminations donc très
probablement le gouvernement prendra une
position intermédiaire
il se peut effectivement connaît plutôt
un confinement un peu plus léger de ce
que l'on a connu en octobre novembre
olivier henno dans votre région nord pas
de calais a été re confiner le week-end
est ce que pour vous et bien les
résultats ont été suffisamment efficace
on entend que les hauts de france
pourraient être concernés par de
nouvelles décisions de nouvelles
restrictions
alors la situation est préoccupante
comme ça a été dit précédemment en ile
de france comme dans les autres français
où on craignait un on le craignait les
chiffres que nous donnait la rs on le
craignait un puisque dès le mois de
février
je crois que xavier bertrand présidents
des deux régions de haute france s'était
inquiété et peut-être d'ailleurs alors
je les exprime depuis longtemps les
principes
humilité de territorialité et puis de
progressivité
donc je vais essayer de les appliquer à
moi même mais peut-être qu'on n'a pas
saisi le moment des vacances scolaires
de février pour faire preuve de
prévention bon c'est comme ça on va pas
vous auriez l'aurait sur le fascicule
est répandu mais enfin il ya des choses
qui ont marché moyennement le couvre-feu
de 18h par exemple marche moyennement
puisque on voit les personnes se se
précipiter faut pas être définitif dans
sa communication puisque on demande aux
gouvernements se l'appliquer à
nous-mêmes mais on voit bien que c'est
comme ça que quand on est obligé d'agir
par rapport à cette épidémie c'est en
fonction du nombre de lits en
réanimation libre ou ou pas libre qui à
un moment donné on est amené à prendre
des décisions d'un certain point de vue
ça veut dire aussi que dans la course
contre la montre puisque c'était
l'expression entre lakovic 19 et puis la
vaccination il semble que la copie de 19
je le crains jeu je le redoute j'en suis
triste et bien je crains que la copie de
19 est en train de gagner cette course
contre la montre c'est préoccupant
vous êtes d'accord avec cela xavier
iacovelli vous venez nous rejoindre en
plateau on évoquait à l'instant les
chiffres qui sont quand même très très
dur en ile-de-france et le fait que
gabriel attal annonce des décisions
prochaine et pour les hauts de france et
pour l'île de france c'est le moment
pour vous écouter cet après midi il y
aura une effectivement une concertation
avec les élus locaux de ces deux régions
pour permettre de de concerter les
mesures supplémentaires mais c'est sûr
qu'on aura des mesures supplémentaires
le porte parole du gouvernement l'a
annoncé à l'instant donc on aura des
mesures supplémentaires je pense que
c'était nécessaire parce qu'on voit que
malgré les contraintes et ce n'est pas
des demi mesures comme j'ai pu
l'entendre
le confinement le week-end pour les
hauts de france où le couvre-feu à 18
heures en ile de france ce n'est pas des
demi-mesures c'est des mesures
contraignantes pour pour les français et
donc malgré ces mesures contraignantes
on voit bien qu'il ya encore une
évolution du taux d'incidence est qui
qui pose problème et qu'ils saturent ou
juin confinement 1re confinement toute
la semaine pour vous et je pense moi je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas plus d'éléments que
ce qui a été dit en conférence de presse
donc je pense qu'il y aura enfin il
sight annoncé y aura des mesures
supplémentaires est ce que ce sera un
confinement uniquement le week-end sur
le modèle des hauts de france avec la
limite que ce que ça pue avoir on le
voit dans cette région a certainement
faire plus dans les hauts de france ou
est ce qu'il y aura un confinement plus
large ou une autre solution je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas je pense que encore
une fois la seule chose qui peut nous
permettre de sortir de cette crise et de
ses confinement un couvre feu c'est
l'accélération de la vaccination et on
voit bien qu'on est aussi en attente à
la fois de l'arrivée de johnson and
johnson au mois deux enfin le milieu
avril après l'avis américain la seule
dose une seule dose et astrazeneca la
décision de l'ema à partir de demain
jean daniel lévy on a eu longtemps un
pour l'ile-de-france un traitement un
petit peu particulier on a beaucoup
évoqué le fait qu'il n'y avait pas eu
leur confinement le week-end malgré bien
certains départements avec un taux
d'incidence dépassant les 400 ça
s'explique notamment par ce que disait
bruno megaman par l'excellent
l'acceptabilité sociale est ce que pour
vous aujourd'hui l'opinion est prête à
accepter un nouveau confinement
elle est prêt les résignés pour paris
c'est dire que ne ce n'est pas forcément
qu'il puisse y avoir un nouveau
confinement
en l'état actuel des choses ne vont pas
forcément d'autres alternatives qui
permettraient de faire réduire nos
risques sanitaires
ce qui est assez surprenant c'est que
l'on peut voir aujourd'hui que nous
avons 85 % des français comme 85% des
personnes qui habitent en ile-de-france
qui sont préoccupés par la situation
sanitaire qui aujourd'hui disent on
souhaite qu'il faille agir quelques
semaines ils s'attendaient à ce qu'il
puisse y avoir un compliment
depuis les annonces on s'en rappelle d'
emmanuel macron et surtout de jean
castex depuis l'elysée
il ya eu de la perception que bon bah
c'est ainsi a vu par exemple elles il y
avait deux pavillons sud africain ou
encore brésilien mais peut-être qu'on
allait éviter ce troisième confinement
il le souhaitait il aspirait ils ont
reconnu d'ailleurs hey mama ou le fait
qu'il n'est pas forcément déclenché
immédiatement sur processus de
recrutement mais peut-être également en
même temps sans vouloir les incriminer
ils ont un peu levé la garde et dans les
différentes enquêtes qu'on est amené à
réaliser
on peut voir qu'on est face à des
français qui sont un peu mon costume qui
sont un peu moins attentifs au respect
de ce qu'on appelle les gestes barrière
qui vont peut plus faire la bise à leurs
proches qu'ils vont un peu moins m
l'embase qu'un peu moins respecté la
distance de 2 m 20 par rapport aux
personnes avec lesquelles ils peuvent
vivre dans le cadre de leur
environnement notamment professionnelle
un peu plus d'ailleurs il faut le dire
retourner au travail et un peu moins
accepter le télétravail et comme étant
la norme un thème est donc tout ceci est
la litra peut participer
j'ai fait qu'on soit aujourd'hui dans
cette situation ils sont
psychologiquement pas vraiment prêt à
pouvoir retrouver une situation de
confinement et peut-être que la question
qui sera la question centrale sera pas
uniquement à la question du confinement
apprendre à en parler mais déjà la
question du rapport aux écoles et du fn
est ce que sa voix est ce que les
enfants vont être avec leurs parents ou
retourner à l'école au collège et lycée
ça s'explique notamment par cette
lassitude un des français ça fait un an
maintenant et bien que la la la pandémie
et que les le premier confinement fait
donc sans son anniversaire
vous en avez parlé on a beaucoup entendu
l'exécutif dire répété que chaque jour
sans confinement c'était un jour de
gagné c'est une stratégie qui
aujourd'hui interroge notamment dans
l'opposition
écoutez le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste olivier faur pour lui le
président de la république a fait des
paris et prend des risques
moi je ne suis pas là pour faire des
paris mais là pour faire moi j'ai du
solide du dur j'avais que les gens
comprennent que ce qu'on fait est la
meilleure solution
alors est-ce que tu aimais bien prudente
de la part du gouvernement de dire qu'on
gagne hachette à paris et comme tous les
paris
un jour on gagne un jour on perd on a
aujourd'hui un président qui considèrent
qu'ils les épidémiologistes qui les
médecins qui est enfin il est tout
puisqu'en fait il est omniscient
donc il sait tout et il prend la
décision tout seul homme ce que je vois
c'est que parfois quand on confine tôt
eh bien on confine moins longtemps du
profit confine tard bon ça reste encore
à prouver bruno m'égare bahn ne par
confiner plutôt l'ile-de-france est ce
que pour vous eh bien c'était un pari
explique et puis aussi comment expliquer
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
en termes de lits de réanimation de quoi
manquons-nous de place de lee de
matériel de main surtout comment
expliquer tout cela alors il est vrai
effectivement que s'ils ont confiné tôt
on pourrait confiné moins longtemps pour
atteindre le même niveau de circulation
du virus
malgré tout effectivement à la sortie de
ceux d'un tel confinement il aurait
fallu imposer des mesures de restriction
pour éviter une reprogrammation de
l'épidémie on voit bien qu'en allemagne
le confinement a eu lieu plus tôt dans
l'épidémie est malheureusement dès la
sortie de l'épisode du confinement il
leur fallut recombiner donc en fait moi
je suis plutôt on va dire partisan de
l'idée qu' effectivement plus on gagne
une semaine sans confinement mieux c'est
pour un peu tout le monde
malgré tout effectivement il faut faire
attention cette stratégie doit être
revue en permanence et adaptée à la
situation épidémiologique et aujourd'hui
on voit que la progression reprend les
aubes les services de la nation sont
saturés il faut désormais effectivement
malheureusement se résoudre à prendre la
décision d'un confinement
alors pourquoi les services de
réanimation sont autant saturé parce
qu'en fait évidemment nous étions sur un
plateau très haut avec des
contaminations qui induisait en
permanence des patients plus graves qui
ne nécessitaient la réanimation et il
faut savoir que nous avons un nombre de
l'illimité à capacitaire limitée
d'ailleurs à mon sens
insuffisant y compris dans des
situations habituelles d'hiver où tous
ou pour tous les ans nous sommes en
position de deux difficultés où nous
prenons en charge les patients de façon
parfois limite nous devons transférer et
donc effectivement devant ce manque de
lits devant cette arrivée de patients
qui s'accumulent en réanimation car
effectivement les patients sont
globalement plus grave il faut compter
une fois que vous rentrez l'animation au
moins un bon mois d'hospitalisation
donc effectivement on en arrive à cette
situation
deux possibilités on est et on va dire
envisager la première c'est le transfert
interrégionale malheureusement ça n'a
pas marché car beaucoup de familles
refusent en fait le transfert de leurs
proches vers des régions éloignées
ce d'autant plus qu'à la différence de
mars/avril désormais ils ont le droit de
visite
lorsqu'ils sont en réanimation à côté et
le second moyen c'est la déprogrammation
d'interventions chirurgicales non
urgentes
et là c'est vrai on peut le faire dans
une certaine mesure mais si on va au
delà on prend des risques de réduire de
l'offre de soins est donc bien sûr de
d'handicapés un certain nombre de
patients atteints d'autres pathologies
dans leur succès de leur prise en charge
donc on est assis aujourd'hui à un
niveau où effectivement on pourrait
prendre des risques pour les patients
locaux vides et donc effectivement il
faut malheureusement procéder à des
restrictions plus importante
xavier iacovelli malheureusement dans
l'impression que depuis un an les choses
n'ont pas tellement changé on a toujours
les mêmes problèmes il faut des
programmes et il faut évacuer et les
le nombre de lits de réanimation n'est
toujours pas suffisant café l'exécutif
dans ce contexte alors moi déjà je
voudrais répondre aux propos du premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste je peux
pas laisser dire aujourd'hui que le
président de la république et le
gouvernement ont fait un pari avec la
santé des français
il y a eu une mesure entre à la fois les
conséquences d'un maintien et d'une
ouverture avec un couvre feu et les
conséquences en cas de confinement total
on sait très bien qu'il ya une
augmentation des dépressions une
augmentation de la détresse aussi des
plus jeunes mais pas seulement des plus
jeunes y également les personnes âgées
isolées
il y à cette détresse importante c'est
ce taux de suicides aussi qui qui
augmente donc on a aussi besoin d'avoir
toutes ces données là pour prendre une
décision et c'est une décision
effectivement politique assumée mais ce
n'est pas un pari avec la santé des
français et je précise parce que en fait
quand je regarde moi la situation et
quand il dit on confine plus tôt on
confinera moins longtemps mais le
professeur mais gardanne l'a dit à
l'instant en allemagne on peut l'espérer
en a mais sauf que quand on regarde nos
voisins nos voisins allemands mais nos
voisins allemands ont fait le 15
décembre un confinement très stricte en
fermant commerces écoles depuis le 15
décembre et nous pas rouverts jusqu'à
maintenant et alors qu'ils ont une
évolution du taux d'incidence en italie
il avait un confinement assez stricte
également ils ont réouvert ils sont en
train de refermer pour leur quatrième
confinement donc on voit bien que la
situation d'un confinement total n'est
pas forcément la solution miracle et je
parle sous couvert du professeur et
garonne mais je crois que pour un une
stratégie et 0 que vides il faut entre 4
à 6 mois de confinement total
c'est-à-dire plus aucune interaction
entre les gens donc je ne suis pas sûr
aujourd'hui que nous soyons en capacité
de le faire
mais une chose qui perdure olivier henno
c'est qu'on a l'impression que notre
système de santé que l'hôpital est bien
n'est toujours pas armé outillés pour
faire face à cette situation
quand on voit qu'on doit toujours
prendre le même type de décision la
déprogrammation l'évacuation essaie de
faire de la place on a toujours pas
assez de place en terme de lits de
réanimation
moi je crois qu'effectivement le
le mot paris n'est peut-être pas le plus
juste mais en même temps on fait des
choix c'est la politique et on a le
droit de critiquer les juges et qui sont
pas totalement pertinent moi je crois
par exemple que le couvre-feu à 18
heures n'est pas un choix pertinent les
gens se bousculent pour faire leurs
courses et je ne vois pas en quoi ce
choix et et pertinents maintenant je
reconnais que que c'est complexe par
rapport par rapport à votre question et
il est évident que j'en viens il ya ya
ya
on a quelquefois nous les français trop
critique sur nous-mêmes mais quelquefois
on a tendance à se voir un peu trop
beaux voiliers et on a du mal à trouver
la juste mesure
il est évident que notre système de
santé on le croyait plus adaptable et
plus solide qu'il ne se révèle dans
cette crise du coc vide 19
idem pas seulement en france mais à
l'évidence il ya des pays qui ont mieux
mener leur campagne vaccinale que nous
l'avons menée en france et en europe
c'est une réalité
voilà on a le droit de critiquer ça
l'europe
moi je suis je suis militant européen
depuis très longtemps mais l'europe
s'est comportée et la france un peu dans
une logique d'acheteurs alors que
d'autres pays les états unis à
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
on va on va créer cette nouvelle
instance là mais d'être organisateurs de
peut-être producteurs d'être développeur
la question des vaccins si on est
aujourd'hui dans cette situation là
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas été très juste
dans la dans la guerre vaccinale qu'il
fallait mener est très pertinent c'est
une évidence
à ce propos et bien il est vrai que plus
que jamais seul une vaccination massive
semble pouvoir désigner le bout du
tunnel c'est dans ce contexte et bien
qu'on a eu cette nouvelle de la
suspension de l'utilisation du vaccin
astrazeneca soupçonnée de créer des
caillots sanguins chez certaines
personnes vaccinées alors l'agencé
européenne du médicament doit rendre son
verdict demain
hier la directrice a tenté de rassurer à
ce propos on va aller rejoindre
alexandre poussard qui était avec la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales et catherine de roche pour une
réaction
et oui catherine de roche qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de cette suspension
temporaire de la vaccination avec le
vaccin
astrazeneca dans plusieurs pays
européens dont la france et ce qu'on ne
touche pas aux limites
le principe de précaution oui moi je
pense que la france n'a pas d'autre
choix que de suspendre dans la mesure où
beaucoup de pays voisins l'avaient fait
alors certes nous nous avions dit ce
n'est le professeur fisher la semaine
dernière qui nous avait vanté l'asra
zeneca par rapport à une efficacité
accrue comparativement aux annonces du
début par la possibilité de
l'administrer à une population très
large bon néanmoins il y a des cas en
effet thromboemboliques qui sont
concomitants à la vaccination il faut
voir aussi s'il ya un lien de cause à
effet mesdames mesure où le pays voisin
le faisait il me semble raisonnable que
la france le fasse aussi on va voir ce
que nous dit en revanche la chance
européenne après sur la méthode
c'est vrai que l'on peut regretter que
les médecins et les pharmaciens
autorisés à vacciner l'a appris par la
presse et n'ai reçu que quelques heures
plus tard l'information
mais en cette décision de suspendre ce
vaccin temporairement est ce que ça ne
peut pas créer une défiance
supplémentaire des français vis-à-vis de
ce vaccin inévitablement parce que déjà
c'est un vaccin qui donne des réactions
immédiates à type de grippe donc qui
parfois est refusée par les soignants à
qui on propose une vaccination week-end
mais qu'ils disent mais on est surchargé
notre seule pause on va la passer
voilà passé ce coup ci je puis dire par
par le vaccin
il y aura sûrement une méfiance après
s'il agence européenne donne des
arguments disons clairement que le
vaccin est sans risque je pense que la
confiance reviendra et puis il ya des
pistes aussi de vaccins qui vont arriver
sur assez rapidement je l'espère on
parle d'une johnson & johnson qui pourra
peut-être prendre prendre le relais par
rapport à ce qui serait méfiants et oui
il ya d'autres pistes ce matin vous avez
auditionné le patron de l'entreprise
sanofi est ce qu'il ya un espoir un jour
de trouver un vaccin français est ce que
ça pourrait accélérer notre campagne
vaccinale
oui j'ai trouvé que l'audition du
président de sanofi était très
intéressante parce qu'il a été clair
dans ses réponses il n'a pas masqué les
choses les questions et parfois c'est
assez critique
néanmoins il nous a dit en effet qu'il y
avait eu deux vaccins arn messagers
également sur lesquels ils ont une
possibilité de délivrance en fin d'année
et puis un vaccin plus type grippal on
peut dire mais on espère que tout le
monde sera vacciné d'essayer de votre
vaccin sortent néanmoins c'est qu'on
évite oriente vraisemblablement vers des
vaccinations itérative et puis aura
d'autres pays qui vont avoir besoin de
vaccin et c'est bien si la france en est
fait peut être positionné sur des
vaccins contre la grippe et sur la
position de la france et des pays
européens dans cette campagne vaccinale
ya une certaine lenteur quand même
européenne sur la scène internationale
est ce que c'est par un échec de l'union
européenne face aux laboratoires
si c'est forcément ça donne un sentiment
d'échec qui a eu il ya eu cette lenteur
nous n'avons pas sur le territoire
européen
désormais deux vaccins qui sont
disponibles et une lenteur dans l'est
dans la livraison des commandes qui ont
été effectuées c'est vrai qu'il va
falloir en effet se pencher fortement
sur l'autonomie stratégique de l'europe
mais la souveraineté européenne merci
beaucoup
la catherine de roche d'avoir répondu à
nos questions merci beaucoup alexandre
pour cette intervention jean daniel lévy
vous avez réalisé une étude sur
l'opinion des français avec harris
interactive après l'annoncé de la
suspension d'astrazeneca par certains
pays européens avant l'annoncé de la
suspension par la france qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est ce qui ressortait de cette étude
c'est en fait nous avons à réaliser une
fois ci quitte la scène malien qui était
pas au moment où il ya eu l'annoncé de
la suspension montré deux choses 1 on
était face à des français qu'ils étaient
plutôt sceptiques d'un point de vue
général à l'égard des vaccins même s'il
avait l'intention de se faire vacciner
et le deuxième aspect comme vous l'avez
indiqué des français qui avaient une
confiance ni minoritaires
à l'égard du vaccin astrazeneca c'est
assez singulier parce qu'en fait en
général les français on sait sur chacun
des organismes associatifs de pouvoir
créer le vaccin et que là une
focalisation forte autour d'un vaccin
autour d'eux conséquence et d'effets
secondaires qui sont identifiés et que
celui ci est apparu comme étant celui ci
qui génère le plus d'inquiétudes votre
vos interventions présentées montraient
bien ça n'est pas uniquement les
français qui sont là mais il manque de
la part des médecins
cette forme d'interrogations de doutes
est ce que j'ai vraiment envie de me
faire vacciner par l'astre à zenica qui
en dehors des effets secondaires tels
qu'ils ont été indiquées et c'était sur
la santé peuvent donner à voir une forme
de fatigue ou de fatigue manifeste qui
crée un doute ou des interrogations de
la part de nos compatriotes
bruno m'égare ban effectivement
astrazeneca c'est un vaccin qui a
suscité la méfiance notamment la
méfiance de certains soignants
est-ce que vous aujourd'hui et bien vous
preniez vous prenez ces effets
indésirables au sérieux ce que c'est
pour vous inquiétant et ça justifie la
décision qui a été prise par de nombreux
pays européens dont la france ou bien
est ce que ce sont des principes de
précaution un peu excessive d'un moment
nous sommes non pour moi c'est un
principe excessif de précaution la
balance bénéfices risques est très en
faveur de la vaccination elle protège
contre les formes graves de lakovic 19
est donc évident que le décès et ça
c'est d'ailleurs reconnu par la totalité
des scientifiques des hommes politiques
simplement je regrette effectivement que
les pays en dominos et les uns après les
autres
suivi le danemark et qui est reconnu
pour avoir des positions extrêmes de
prudence de risque zéro évidemment comme
vous le savez aucun médicament d'un
risque zéro même si vous prenez du
paracétamol il existe des risques ou
prenaient de l'aspirine vous avez un
risque vers une allergie donc le risque
zéro n'existe pas les effets secondaires
observés sérieux de type maladie
thromboembolique sont relativement
exceptionnel on va dire quand bien même
un lien d'imputabilité ou de cause à
effet qui était établie en aucun cas ils
ne remettent en cause la balance
bénéfice risque il faut savoir que
prendre la pilule contraceptive en soi
augmente le risque de maladies
thromboemboliques c'est pas pour autant
qu'on a retirés du marché la pilule un
mot pour conclure messieurs sûr et bien
que faudrait-il faire parce
qu'astrazeneca que on le suspende ou qui
y ait des retards comme ça a été annoncé
ça va avoir un véritable impact sur
notre stratégie de vaccination française
d'art quoi faut-il aller est ce qu il
fallait voir le vaccin rue c'est ce
qu'il faut miser sur le vaccin français
et la recherche chez sanofi comme on a
pu l'entendre ce matin que la vie à
cofely
déjà nous avons nous allons avoir à peu
près trois jours de retard si les
éléments se confirme les éléments qu'on
a pour l'instant de l'ema se confirme
normalement l'astra zeneca pourrait
reprendre en vaccination donc on aura
perdu trois jours mais c'est pas trop à
venir à des retards
oui mais ce geste est patent on ne peut
pas qu'on ne peut pas récupérer
notamment parce que les stocks sont
restés les vaccins qui n'ont pas été
donnés d'astrazeneca sur ces trois jours
sont gars sont gardés et donc pourront
être injectés aux français dès qu'on
aura l'aval de l'autorité européenne
donc moi je pense qu'il va falloir fait
qu effectivement reprendre la confiance
le premier ministre l'a annoncé hier
qu'il pourrait se faire vacciner avec
l'astra zeneca pour montrer aussi la
confiance vis-à-vis des français
vis-à-vis de cette de ce vaccin
donc voilà je pense que ça sera aussi de
la pédagogie ou à la fois les médias et
les politiques
bien sûr les soignants devront aussi
faire preuve de dynamisme pour les
convaincre les français olivier henno le
mot de la fin sera alors le mot de la
fin d'abord dire que d'avoir un vaccin
aussi rapidement des vaccins aussi
rapidement maîtrisé le le président de
sanofi s'est quand même prouesse puisque
pour ebola il y avait fallu quatre ans
moi je pense à titre personnel que c'est
un principe de précaution qui s'exerce
comme l'a dit le professeur de manière
un peu excessive
curieuse d'ailleurs dans l'organisation
parce que c'est l'effet domino comme ça
a été dit puis l'allemagne décidé nous
on suit moi je n'étais pas très chaud
mais maintenant c'est défendre devant
ces livres si la défense devant
l'opinion mais c'est sûr que ça donne
quand même une sentiment de désordre et
il aurait mieux valu alors une décision
européenne
dans l'ordre plutôt que cet effet domino
mais moi je crois à la vaccination et je
crois que c'est grâce à la vaccination
1 une seule solution la vaccination
comment disait aux lycées la vaccination
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat dans
une demi heure maintenant commencer bien
les questions au gouvernement nos
journalistes sont en place alexandre
pousse à salade et conférence jean
mercier anime son émission sur twitch
avec sa communauté et style jourdain est
toujours dans l'hémicycle vous pouvez
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur le
thème marquant de cet après midi car
c'est clairement une après midi
kovy d'aujourd'hui un convive qu'ovide
est encore qu'au vide tam avec et donc
l'hypothèse d'un reconfirme ans de la
région ile de france jean castex lui
même l'a évoqué hier soir et puis on
sait que deux autres régions sont
concernés par un éventuel confinement
c'est le cas de la région hôte france et
de la région paca au total ce sont près
de 23 millions d'habitants en france qui
sont concernés par un éventuel
reconfirme ans alors trois présidents de
groupes vont interpeller jean castex à
ce sujet aujourd'hui ce sera le cas côté
socialiste côté républicain et puis côté
communiste est toujours sur la crise
sanitaire il sera aussi question est
bien des aides économiques débloqués par
le gouvernement vers et bien les
secteurs les plus sinistrés on pense au
secteur de l'événementiel ou au secteur
du sport est ce que et bien ces aides
sont elles réellement suffisante la
parole est au gouvernement dans un peu
moins de 30 minutes maintenant
merci steve et on se retrouve on vous
retrouve donc d'un peu moins de 30
minutes
à tout à l'heure on va passer aux fins a
pas au face à face on va parler de la
proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale
ce texte élaboré issu des rangs lrm à
l'assemblée nationale était à l'origine
de la crise politique de l'automne
depuis les esprits se sont apaisés le
sénat a largement réécrit les articles
les plus polémiques le texte est en
examen dans l'hémicycle pour en débattre
sur ce plateau agnès canayer bonjour
bonjour n'atterrisse les républicains de
seine-maritime secrétaire de la
commission des lois est avec nous sur ce
plateau cécile cukierman bonjour
être communiste de la loire vice
présidente de la commission des lois et
retour d'abord bien sûr l'ouverture des
débats hier dans l'hémicycle où on a vu
le gouvernement se ranger derrière la
rédaction du sénat celle de la majorité
sénatoriale et c'est un petit peu le
retour du clivage droite gauche hier
dans l'hémicycle récit par jeremiah une
semaine quelques centaines de personnes
devant le sénat la mobilisation était
moins forte ce mardi autour de la
proposition de loi sécurité globale
notamment après la réécriture de
l'article 24 par les sénateurs qui
prévoit la création d'un délit de
provocation à l'identification des
forces de l'ordre dans l'hémicycle le
ministre de l'intérieur a également joué
la carte de l'apaisement tant que le but
essentiel légitime important de protéger
nos policiers de gendarmes dans leurs
actions et garder le gouvernement sera à
la sagesse des amendements du rapporteur
et je sais que healy à travailler dans
ce sens pour protéger nos forces lors
d'un je l'en remercie
la majorité sénatoriale de droite a elle
réaffirmé son soutien aux policiers
tout ce qui peut être voter pour assurer
la sécurité des français et la
protection de ceux qui en sont les
garants est une excellente chose
si on pose et c'est encore plus mettant
en péril leur sécurité
pourtant d'autres éléments du texte
cristallise encore les débats comme
l'article 21 sur l'utilisation des
caméras piétons l'article 22 concernant
l' usage de drones ou encore l'article
25 autorisant le port de larmes
hors service dans les lieux publics la
gauche dénonce ce qu'elle appelle une
dérive sécuritaire l'espace public
devient un espace de contrôle et de
suspicion chaque citoyen étant considéré
comme un suspect potentiel voit comme un
terroriste potentiel quoi qu'il en soit
comme une menace
nous rejetons ce texte sur une base très
politique car il est porteur selon nous
d'un projet de société extrêmement
dangereux la motion déposée par les
communistes est rejetée mais les
tensions sont ravivées mais les 102
mélenchonisation que je ne peux accepter
non non par ailleurs les sénateurs ont
adopté dans la soirée l'article 1
étendant les pouvoirs des polices
municipales et l'article 4 autorisant la
création d'une police municipale à paris
là on va essayer de prendre ces articles
par article est tout d'abord on va
parler de l'article 24 cet article
polémique avait concentré bien sûr les
polémiques la crise politique de
l'automne donc c'est un article a été
substantiellement modifié par la
majorité sénatoriale agnès canayer elles
mêmes partis d'une page blanche
en quoi cet article dit fertile de
l'original aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui a
été modifié effectivement cet article
est totalement réécrit de a à z et grâce
aux travaux du sénat et sahel le sénat
elle remplit sur cet article là son vrai
rôle de législateur et il nous était
important que ce soit les sénateurs et
les la commission des lois qui soit à
l'origine de ce texte et non pas une
commission extérieure comme cela était
prévu un moment donné par le
gouvernement sur le contenu de ce texte
il change totalement la philosophie
alors il part de la nécessité
effectivement d'empêcher que des images
de policiers en exercice soit mis sur
les réseaux sociaux pour ces derniers
soient soumis à l'avis dépens de
communes oui il crée un délit de
provocation à l'identification des
policiers tous les très différent de ce
qu'il y avait au départ oui tout à fait
c'est à dire que du coup l'angle là et
sous l'angle pénal et non pas sous
l'angle de la loi de 1881
ce qui change totalement la philosophie
et qui réprime uniquement ceux qui
commettent ces actes qui sont
répréhensibles de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé
donc on est vraiment sur la création
d'un nouveau délit ciblées et qui à mon
avis touche vraiment la cible recherchée
qu'est ce qui pose encore pour vos
problèmes dans la rédaction de cet
article cécile qu'éclairent menace qu'il
atteint encore et bien les libertés
publiques notamment
on a évoqué bien sûr beaucoup la liberté
de la presse ou la liberté d'information
mais ce que pour vous il ya encore des
risques avec cette rédaction
oui encore des risques mais d'ailleurs
je crois que il serait trompeur de
résumer finalement le débat
sa proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale uniquement à cet article parce
que finalement l'ensemble de sa
proposition à vise à inverser quelque
peu le paradigme de qu'est ce que doit
être la politique en matière de sécurité
de la part de l'état et finalement on le
voit un désengagement progressif de
l'état dans sa mission régalienne
première qui est celle d'assurer la
sécurité de chacune et de chacun
il crée dans l'arène souvent à la police
municipale c'est cela qui est prêt à
lizio nema plus ou moins de pouvoirs à
la police municipale la question est
quel type de pouvoir londres l'ont
décentralise quelque part de quel poids
on se défausse ça va un pouvoir
judiciaire en l'occurrence face à une
police municipale qui n'existe pas sur
l'ensemble du territoire et à laquelle
les communes n'ont pas les moyens tout
de répondre et donc on est bien sûr une
question quand même qui est que une
grande mission régalienne attendu par
chacune et chacun va demain être à la
carte est donc renforcée des inégalités
territoriales en matière d'accès à cette
sécurité mais sur l'article 24 de la
curée écrit d'abord il est important que
soient les parlementaires qui écrivent
la loi et non pas effectivement une
commission théodule ou je ne sais quoi
extérieur à tout cela donc ça c'est un
premier point il y a bien évidemment des
améliorations j'ai envie de dire c'était
assez facile parce qu'on ne pouvait pas
faire pire je crois que ce qui avait été
sortie nationale
cependant pour nous il demeure encore
beaucoup de fous sur la première partie
notamment de de cet article et le risque
que demain il y ait des interprétations
et que finalement tout soit soumis à
interprétation et que cela pose débat
même si nous devons rester avoir la
garantie de sécuriser les personnes en
tant que tel et donc les individus
agents de des forces de l'ordre et puis
toute une deuxième partie finalement qui
redit ce qui existe déjà dans notre
droit dans notre jurisprudence à travers
notamment les préconisations de la cnil
et c'est au tour d'un autre et donc la
vraie question et nous aurons débat
peut-être pas ce soir peut-être plus
demain d'ailleurs sur cet article 24 au
rythme de nos débats
effectivement oui nous pensons qu'il
faut le supprimer parce qu'il faut en
sortir mais je le redis
l'enjeu de cette loi ne peut pas et ne
se concentre pas pour tout un chacun et
pour tout les concitoyens et concitoyens
sur cet article 24 mais bel et bien sur
un ensemble une philosophie générale il
ya beaucoup de mesures dans ce texte
l'argent autour de la police municipale
il ya aussi un autre article qui a été
largement modifié par le sénat c'est
l'article 21 le sénat a retiré la
possibilité pour le ministère
d'exploiter les images des caméras
piétons pour communiquer qu'est ce que
l'on craignait
avec cette mesure à dsk mais est ce que
vous vous êtes d'accord avec avec cette
suppression
oui bien évidemment d'abord là aussi une
question de méthode parce que je vous
rappelle que c'est une proposition de
loi qui est à l'origine de ce texte
d'ampleur et qui dit proposition de loi
dit qu'elle n'a été soumis à aucune
étude d'impact ni même d'avis du conseil
d'état qui garantit quand même la
constitutionnalité et le les effets
réels du texte envisagé heureusement la
commission des lois sous l'impulsion de
son président françois noël buffet a
demandé la cnil quand même son avis qui
nous a donné à celle qu'un cadre et ce
qui m'a permis aussi d'introduire un
certain nombre de modifications pour
garantir les libertés
puisque tout la philosophie aussi de
teck celle équilibre entre la nécessaire
nécessaire renforcement de la sécurité
et la garantie de nos libertés et
l'article 21 vient mettre des verrous
pour éviter qu'on ait une trop grande
atteinte à la liberté notamment par
l'exploitation de d'image ou de fichiers
individualisé qu'est ce qu'on pouvait
craindre avec cet article c'est que
carmen pour le coup ça fait plutôt un
consensus est plutôt un consensus parce
que je crois est peut-être là le sénat
on retrouve aussi sous raids
et dans son rôle et quand j'en mets ta
puce dans sa réputation et dans sa
tradition effectivement de vraiment
garantir les libertés sans hystériser ni
d'un côté ni de l'autre quelque chose et
finance la vraie crainte avec cet
article 21 ses comptes
on a envoyé bien se pointer une bataille
publique de vidéos contre vidéo et je
crois que voilà
le travail aujourd'hui qui a été
effectué par la commission des lois qui
devrait être validée en séance permet
cela devrait empêcher d'en arriver là et
peut-être parce que un des défis
finalement indépendamment ce texte de
loi c'est de réconcilier nos construire
nos concitoyens avec celles et ceux dont
la mission première est de les protéger
et de garantir leur liberté or on sait
et on le constate tous on n'y apporte
pas les mêmes réponses politiques
c'est la démocratie mais en tout cas
qu'il y a aujourd'hui une fracture réel
et une crise de confiance entre eux une
partie de la population et les forces de
l'ordre
si on va sur à un point de vue un petit
peu plus politique on a assisté hier
bien un relatifs accord entre la droite
sénatoriale et la république en marche
écoutez à ce propos est bien françois
noël buffet le président ait l'air de la
commission des lois s'est exprimé sur ce
climat dans l'hémicycle ce matin il
était l'invité de rayonnement de fini
dans bonjour chez vous se passe bien je
suis content que le ministre entend de
ce que dit le sénat est ce qu a dit la
commission des lois en particulier nous
sommes pour une efficacité de la bonne
au service de sécurité des polices bien
évidemment nous sommes pour protéger des
français bien sûr mais nous sommes aussi
vigilants mais c'est notre rôle de
parlementaires de ne pas aller trop loin
dans des réglementations qui permettrait
par exemple à des drones de survoler
votre domicile et de pouvoir vous
prendre en photo très facilement parce
que vous faites alors que vous êtes dans
le cadre de votre vie privée
est ce qu'il frappe cécile cukierman nc
que sur ce texte la droite et la
république en marche se retrouve un
souvent sur les mêmes positions qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire
bah écoutez je pose sa frappe quoi bon
je crois qu'à pas idiot c'est sans
surprise beaucoup dit parfois que le
sénat pourrait être une force
d'opposition sur des textes clairs qui
tique traite aux questions de sécurité
il n'y a pas d'évolution gens de
doctrine et positionnement des uns et
des autres je crois qu'on a ce débat-là
incompris effectivement avec parfois un
ministre qui a même un peu en retrait
par rapport à ses ambitions peut être
qui il entend il comprend que vous ne
peut pas tout ça et tout ne se décide
pas à l'assemblée nationale je crois que
c'est tout cas c'est une des forces de
ce bicamérisme mais plus sûr sur la
question
son voile c'est un texte sécuritaire
supplémentaire qui se rajoutent y
compris on est ainsi période d'état
d'urgence des fonds tant à l'oublier
mais cet état d'urgence qui qui se perd
est mis aujourd'hui et donc pour lequel
je redis la vraie question qui demeure
est qui reste posée est qu'est-ce
qu'elle sera demain la mission de la
police nationale et avec quels moyens
or aujourd'hui on a tout un certain
nombre d'articles y compris qu'ils vont
mercantilise et cette politique
sécuritaire pourtant tant attendu avec
notamment le recours à un certain nombre
de sociétés privées c'était aussi cette
arrivée est ce que pour vous agnès
canayer le sénat joue son rôle de
défenseur des libertés publiques
essentiellement dans ce texte
est ce que l'on voit pas aussi bien la
majorité cet intérieur la majorité
présidentielle en train de se mettre
d'accord sur une ligne sécuritaire et là
pour le coup y avait des vrais sujets
déçu du vrai sujet d'accord je ne sais
pas si c'est un accord global c'est au
moins un constat que partage et ont même
le partage et parfois avec l'opposition
au sénat sur la nécessité de restaurer
la confiance des citoyens dans la
sécurité et dans ceux qui agissent au
quotidien pour notre sécurité et donc la
garantie de nos libertés
après il ya aussi une vision pragmatique
des choses il faut voir comment ça se
passe sur le terrain il faut voir
aujourd'hui que dans un certain nombre
de territoires alors à tous on est
d'accord mais ces principes de la
différenciation qui sera un autre grand
débat on a déjà des polices nationales
qui travaille en lien avec la police
municipale et on a des polices
municipales qui sont très présentes sur
le terrain et qui n'ont pas les moyens
aujourd'hui de remplir les missions qui
pourraient les leurs et qui pourrait
permettre d'avoir une meilleure meilleur
continuum une meilleure coordination
entre ce qui relève de la police
municipale et ce qui relève de la police
nationale
moi je ne pense pas même s'il faut être
vigilant sur les transferts de
compétences et il faut être vigilant
bien évidemment sur le fait que l'état
ne se défausse pas sur les collectivités
territoriales et il n'oblige pas les
mères à endosser les responsabilités
plus grandes que celles qui sont les
leurs mais je ne crois pas que ce soit
un appauvrissement de la police
nationale au bénéfice de la police
municipale elle est on va à présent
rejoindre
jean massiet notre streamer politique
jean tu discutes avec ta communauté
depuis maintenant à peu près 45 minutes
quelles sont leurs sujets de
préoccupation et bien avant un quart
d'heure de cette séance de questions au
gouvernement
et ben écoute tu aimes tu t'en doutes
beaucoup de questions autour de autour
de la situation sanitaire autour des
décisions qui ont pu être prise ce matin
en conseil de défense d'abord une
question que les internautes attendent
beaucoup comment a été prise cette
décision de suspendre le vaccin
astrazeneca pourquoi est-ce qu emmanuel
macron a annoncé lundi que la france
suspende est pour quelques jours ce
vaccin alors qu'encore dimanche soir sur
twitter le président le premier ministre
avait l'air de dire que pour l'instant
en france tout allait bien et que des
cessions pour être prises mais plus tard
pourquoi cette précipitation comment la
décision et elle été prise
ensuite une question aussi de calendrier
cette suppression du vaccin astrazeneca
est ce que ça remet en cause le
calendrier autre manière de parler
d'autres manières de parler est ce que
on continue à tabler ce que le
gouvernement continue à tabler sur une
vaccination d'à peu près toute la
population d'ici à la fin de l'été ou
est ce qu'on prend du retard
est-ce que et s'il ya un retard de
combien de temps ça c'est des questions
assez pratique assez précises qui sont
attendus et enfin très attendu très
sucré voilà très très très redouté 1re
confinement en ile de france pourra être
annoncés éventuellement demain mais quel
type de confinement est ce qu'on se
dirige vers un confinement uniquement le
week-end et ce qu'on garde les écoles
ouvertes
et puis les facs d'ailleurs est ce qu'on
continue à avoir quelques travaux
dirigés en présentiel ou pas tu vois des
questions extrêmement techniques qui
sont attendus on attend vraiment de la
part du gouvernement des réponses
concrètes autant que possible cet après
midi et tous les français sont
effectivement suspendu à ce sujet alors
on n'hésite pas à aider un petit peu
d'autres choses sur ce plateau mais
effectivement on est toujours rattrapé
par la situation sanitaire cécile kerman
et va d'ailleurs y avoir une question de
votre groupe opposé par la présidente de
votre groupe eliane assassi sur le sujet
vous qu'est-ce qui vous interpellent
dans la situation actuelle est alors que
on attend des annonces de leur
confinement possible pour plusieurs
régions alors y est je crois que moi ce
qui m'interpelle tout premier mais
finalement comme les internautes
c'est cette incertitude et 7 c'est ce
sentiment qui je crois est partagé par
les françaises et les français que plus
personne ne sait où l'on va et qu'il est
temps que ce gouvernement pose les
choses dise les choses que l'on n'est
pas des informations
qu'ils soient contredites à midi pour
être contredite le soir et que l'on ait
une perspective à cinq ou six mois pour
savoir effectivement comment les uns et
les autres et bien nous nous comportons
et comment collectivement on sorte de
cette situation sanitaire qui pèsent sur
le quotidien de chacune et de chacun on
pense à une intervention en particulier
jean évoqué à l'instant l'histoire
d'astrazeneca effectivement sur twitch
dimanche jean castex a dit qu'il avait
toute confiance dans ce vaccin et puis
finalement mais bien sûr les suspentes
de laisser ça c'est juste surnaturel
clair que les gens à montner ne s'y
retrouvent pas quand on presque 24
heures on change comme ça de situation
est donc oui les gens sont inquiets
parce que bien évidemment si ce vaccin
est pour l'instant retirer ça prend du
retard sur le peu l'objectif de
vaccination d'ailleurs ce n'était pas
toute la population d'ici à l'été et
déjà enlevé les plus jeunes alors qu'on
voit qu'ils sont aussi des facteurs de
contamination gagnant qu'il y a de
l'inquiétude parce que finalement ce à
quoi aspire chacune et chacun sait à
pouvoir sortir de cette situation de
pandémie pour reprendre tout simplement
cette vie du quotidien qui nous sorte
simplement du travail et travail agnès
canayer en même temps bon bah on
comprend tout
la décision qui a été prise aussi par le
gouvernement c'est très difficile à
tenir à partir du moment où autant de
pays européens avaient choisi de
suspendre le vaccin et notamment
l'allemagne de dire eh bien nous on
continue à vacciner on comprend aussi un
petit peu cette navigation à vue vous
vous dites vous aussi on n'y comprend
rien c'est un manque de perspective
oui alors effectivement il ya un
contexte une instabilité qui est
aujourd'hui réel donc on peut pas
retirer cela au gouvernement qu'il est
obligé de faire face à une situation
d'une partie via le mans grande
instabilité avec l'émergence de tous ces
variants néanmoins moi je rejoins quand
même ce que dit elle même qu kerman
c'est que aujourd'hui on voit bien chez
nos concitoyens ils étouffent
ils sont inquiets et ce dont ils ont
besoin c'est une perspective
c'est au moins alors certes une
transparence mais il ya tellement de
transparence aujourd'hui que finalement
le message était extrêmement troubles
mais ce dont ils ont besoin c'est
d'avoir une perspective
en ce qui concerne effectivement les
mesures qui vont être prises et qu'il
n'y ait pas des contradictions
permanentes et puis surtout une
perspective sur la vaccination
quand bien même il ya des aléas il ya
d'autres vaccins il ya d'autres
possibilités
je voudrais commencer à aller voir
ailleurs à aller voir vers d'autres
vaccins tabler sur une autre stratégie
que celle de l'union européenne qui a
été il est vrai
vraiment peut-être insuffisante sur sur
ces dernières semaines oui puis il
faudrait surtout ça soit il ya des
vaccins comme le vaccin américain qui
doit arriver de johnson johnson est le
plus bas à johnson & johnson il faut
qu'on ait un peu plus de visibilité
il faut aussi sur alors on attend la
réponse effectivement concernant la
stratégie cas mais il faut quand même
pesé aussi le pour et le contre
faut pas tout d'un coup ouvrir des
parapluies énorme parce qu'il ya un
sentiment une inaptitude faut peser
maintenir la décision demain on attend
la chanson en tête du med-it mai mais il
faut à partir de là à voir vraiment un
plan et avoir des perspectives et je
pense que ce que demandent les français
aujourd'hui c'est d'être rassurés et
d'avoir des perspectives
ils accepteront toutes les mesures même
les plus difficiles si derrière il ya
ces perspectives
on attend en tout cas certainement et
bien des annonces pour demain on va
continuer bien les réactions salle des
conférences sur un tout autre sujet
alexandre vous être avec le sénateur et
l'air de l'oise jérôme bascher pour
venir parler et bien de l'ouverture du
procès bygmalion aujourd'hui mais oui le
procès bygmalion le procès de la faire
des fausses factures de la campagne
présidentielle de nicolas sarkozy en
2012 l'ancien président de la république
qui encourt une peine d'un an de prison
jérôme bascher est ce que vous craignez
un procès politique comme la droite
l'avait dénoncé il ya quelques semaines
lors de la condamnation de nicolas
sarkozy dans la sphère des écoutes
écoutez il ya une chose très
particulière c'est que pour la première
fois lordonnance de renvoi n'a été signé
que par un magistrat sur deux donc pour
le président sarkozy c'est un petit peu
bizarre est étonnant c'est une première
historique
on multiplie les premières historiques
sur ces procès politique
un peu un peu dommage donc pour vous il
ya encore des étrangetés dans la
procédure judiciaire qui visent nicolas
sarkozy il y a des étrangetés ce qui
n'empêchera pas la vérité de se
manifester lors de ce procès donc c'est
ça qui est important c'est que la vérité
passe et que la justice passe
alors je lis je le disait l'ancien
président encourt une peine d'un an de
prison pour finir financement illégal de
campagne électorale
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que
cette affaire salissent encore un peu
l'image de votre famille politique la
droite comme moi c'est pas une bonne
image c'est sûr mais faut pas se tromper
qui est vraiment responsable dans cette
affaire c'est hélas j'ai envie de dire
presque les lampistes les numéros 2 qui
n'ont pas eu le courage
clairement c'est ce qui apparaît a
priori dans la presse et dans le dossier
que je ne ok je n'ai pas eu accès qui
n'ont pas su dire non et quand on ne
sait pas dire non parce que ça a
toujours été votre patron que ce soit le
directeur de la campagne que ce soit
directeur général du parti eh bien on
fait pas tout à fait son rôle donc c'est
peut-être le procès du manque de courage
donc pour vous c'est le procédé des
lampistes comme vous dites c'est à dire
que le candidat d'une campagne n'est pas
au courant de l'évolution de ces
dépenses vous savez là non ça c'est
certain ce nom vous faites autre chose
que vous faites une campagne électorale
c'est pour ça que toute personne qui
s'est présentée à une élection c'est
qu'ils voteraient bien choisir son
trésorier
mais au delà le président la république
était totalement d'une part président de
la république
donc il y avait quand même des choses à
faire et d'autre part totalement
candidats donc c'est clairement pas lui
que de s'occuper de la campagne le
trésorier a failli dans cette campagne
le trésorier a fait y est ce que ça peut
raviver les divisions de l'époque entre
les partisans de jean françois copé et
ceux de nicolas sarkozy où je ne crois
pas l'un et l'autre sont assez retiré de
la politique nationale est ce que ça
pourrait quand même avoir un impact je
le disais en sueur sur l'image de la
droite notamment en vue de la
présidentielle non
les gens qui étaient là sont passés ces
deux nouvelles personnes qui sont là ces
deux nouveaux candidats potentiels ils
n'ont pas eu à voir avec ces campagnes
la donc non c'est la page allait tourner
et tourner d'autant plus qu'ils aient eu
deux élections présidentielles en prêt
mais la page est tournée et nouvel air
pour les républicains merci beaucoup
jérôme baschet séance des questions
d'actualité va commencer dans quelques
minutes
merci merci beaucoup l accent ton dès
qu'on voyait arriver pendant 30 ans dans
votre interview un certain nombre de
membres du gouvernement à commencer par
jean castex qui va devoir répondre à
plusieurs questions sur la crise
sanitaire cette après midi on a vu
marlène schiappa on a vu laurent pit
rashevski on a vu également frédéric
vidal un mot de réaction sur ce que nous
disait bien jérôme batx assure
l'ouverture du procès bygmalion
aujourd'hui agnès canayer
on a entendu jérôme bascher qui
incriminait bien on l'a entendu le
trésorier avant tout et des douanes et
un petit peu les autres est ce que vous
êtes de cet avis non moi je pense que
alors effectivement il y à un procès
donc qui va permettre de faire la vérité
et puis d'entendre les uns et les autres
et d'opposer les pas dû je pense que
quand on fait une campagne c'est
collectif et que quand on fait une
campagne c'est une équipe complète qui
il est engagé pour réussir alors que le
chef soit pas forcément au courant de
tout parce qu'évidemment il a d'autres
enjeux et que lui il est là pour mener à
terme sa stratégie c'est certain mais
derrière il ya une équipe globale qui
suit le candidat voilà on va à présent
et bien continuer les réactions et
rejoindre alexandre vous êtes avec l'une
des coûts rapporteur du projet de loi
séparatisme au sénat la sénatrice
dominique veria car ce matin et bien la
commission des lois a travaillé sur ce
texte séparatisme à rejeter un
amendement sur le voile qu'elle portait
avec la co rapporteurs jacqueline
eustache brinio pour l'interdire aux
accompagnatrice de sorties scolaires
effectivement dominique va rien vous
défendiez cet amendement avec votre
collègue rapporteur jacqueline eustache
brinio pour et bien étendre la
neutralité religieuse pour les
accompagnant des sorties scolaires
finalement cet amendement était rejetée
vous
regretté comment vous l'expliquez je le
regrette parce que c'était en fait
étendre à l'extérieur ce qui se passe
déjà à l'intérieur de l'école dans le
même contexte
donc bien sûr je le regrette parce que
ça permettait de clarifier le droit
maintenant on sait que ces sujets là
sont forcément sensible au sein de
toutes les familles politiques
d'ailleurs on peut avoir aussi bien de
droite comme de gauche des gens qui vont
être pour des gens qui vont être contre
notamment par rapport à la neutralité et
comme c'est vrai que sur l'ensemble du
texte on parle beaucoup de la neutralité
je pense que là il ya eu un souhait de
dire que l'important était plus de
respecter le culte que de respecter la
neutralité
voilà c'est fait grâce à ça on en
reparlera un jour c'est évident mais
c'est pas très grave ce n'est pas
l'important du texte objectivement
l'important du texte et 1900 à 1950 pour
les associations
ah oui et l'encadrement des cultes juste
pour revenir sur notamment le port du
voile dans les sorties scolaires le
débat va quand même revenir dans
l'hémicycle puisque une partie de la
droite sénatoriale est très attaché à
cette mesure le sénat l'avait d'ailleurs
voté dans le cadre d'une proposition loi
à bruno retailleau le patron du groupe
il est très très attachés vous pensez
que ça peut passer en séance publique
c'est possible d'autant qu'il n'y a pas
que la droite sénatoriale qui est
attaché à un certain temps mais un
certain mouvement
l'aiic aussi qui demande à ce que la
laïcité jusqu'à la neutralité puisse
appliquer notamment vis-à-vis des
enfants
donc il est possible qu effectivement ça
puisse repasser dans l'hémicycle donc en
fait c'est un débat sur la laïcité qui
est trans partisan au sein du sénat
tout ça c'est que je les vis comme ça
d'accord alors il ya eu un autre point
qui a été et bien l'objet de tensions de
discussions en commission
ce matin ça concerne la laïcité des élus
vous défendiez un amendement pour
renforcer la laïcité des élus locaux
cet amendement était retirée quel était
le but de la mesure
en fait c'était plus d'affichés comme la
république est laïque
ll est neutre et donc de dire que les
élus se devait une certaine devait
respecter la laïcité mais justement pas
la neutralité et je crois qu'il ya eu
une confusion et c'est pourquoi nous
l'avons retirée parce que nous ne
voulions pas absolument pas imposer une
quelconque neutralité d'ailleurs nous le
disions ensuite que c'était on pouvait
garder sa liberté de conscience et de
évidemment donc on nous avons préféré le
retirer plutôt que de laisser croire que
nous demanderions une neutralité aux
élus ce qui n'est pas du tout cas est ce
que vous allez leur déposé en séance
publique il ya un vrai premier cité avec
noé baisse leurs frais sous cette forme
il n'y a pas de problème de laïcité
justement puisque la laïcité permet à
tout le monde d'exercer son culte et
offre une liberté de conscience donc ce
qu'il y assez qui a souvent une
confusion entre laïcité et neutralité et
c'est pour ça que nous n'avons pas voulu
entretenir cette confusion nous ne
demandons pas la neutralité des élus
merci beaucoup dominique verreault
d'avoir répondu à mes questions et alors
que la séance de questions d'actualité
va bientôt commencer et sommes
effectivement et je vais donc vous
laisser merci beaucoup agnès canayer
merci beaucoup cécile qui a man d'avoir
participé à ce face à face et tout de
suite et bien on va rejoindre steve
jourdain dans l'hémicycle du sénat pour
nous donner un aperçu un petit peu plus
large et bien de ce qui nous attend lors
de cette séance
oui séance d'actualité un peu
particulière il faut dire aujourd'hui
parce que puisqu'elle va s'ouvrir par un
discours de gérard larcher discours en
hommage aux soignants un an après le
début du premier confinement est bien le
président du sénat qui va proposer un
moment de recueillement en hommage à
ceux qui ont perdu
ceux qui ont succombé à cette épidémie
en hommage également victime du coc vide
et à leurs proches
moment solennel donc proposé à
l'initiative du président du sénat et
puis ensuite on parlera
on l'a déjà dit beaucoup dans cette
émission est bien de crise sanitaire
la crise sanitaire qui est en quelque
sorte le fil rouge de cet après-midi
alors qu'on évoque et bien l'hypothèse
d'un gros confinement de l'île de france
et jean castex lui même qui l'a laissé
entendre hier soir on sait aussi et bien
que deux régions sont concernées par un
potentiel reconfirme ans c'est le cas
notamment de la région des hautes france
et de la région paca au total ce sont
donc près de 23 millions d'habitants en
france qui sont concernés par un
potentiel confinement alors trois
présidents de vous vont interpeller jean
castex à ce sujet cet après midi ce sera
le cas notamment et bien côté socialiste
côté et les républicains ou encore côté
communiste et puis toujours sur la crise
sanitaire et sur la question et bien d
aide économique apportée par l'état par
le gouvernement secteurs les plus
sinistrés les secteurs signes les plus
sinistrées on pense bien évidemment au
secteur de l'événementiel ou encore au
secteur du sport les ces questions vont
être posées au gouvernement
la séance est ouverte on en reparle tout
de suite après tout à l'heure
la séance est ouverte
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation et en a
t'il en séance
je n'en vois pas il est donc adoptée
sous les réserves d'usagé monsieur le
ils étaient confinés et faisait face à
la pandémie
je voudrais aujourd'hui exprimer la
reconnaissance du sénat à tout le
personnel soignant qui s'est engagé
s'engage totalement au service de nos
compatriotes
certains
[Applaudissements]
certains l'ont payé de leur vie
l'implication le dévouement des
professionnels de santé ont été et sont
exemplaires et nous permettent je
l'espère d'éviter le pire en votre nom à
tous je veux leur rendre hommage
cette épreuve n'est hélas pas terminée
cela renforce encore le sens de cet
hommage du sénat qui au delà les
personnels soignants s'adresse aux
femmes et aux hommes travailleurs de la
première ligne qui ont assuré
l'essentiel dans des moments
particulièrement difficiles
c'est grâce à eux aussi que le pays a
tenu et tient c'est grâce à eux que nous
continuerons de faire face forts de nos
valeurs de solidarité
comment ne pas penser à tous nos
concitoyens qui ont été victimes de
l'épidémie
comment ne pas penser à la douleur de
leurs proches à la souffrance de ceux
qui n'ont pu entrer en contact à ceux
qui portent aujourd'hui les stigmates
alors mes chers collègues ce premier
ministre et dames et messieurs les mini
jeux vous propose en nous levant
d'observer un moment de silence de
recueillement mais surtout de solidarité
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
d'autres séances et retransmise en
direct sur public sénat et sur notre
site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect du sein
et les autres aient du temps de parole
et je donne la parole immédiatement à
madame la présidente eliane assassi pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et écologistes vous avez la parole
madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre depuis un an donc jour
pour jour la france va de confinement
couvre-feu de kobudo couvre-feu en
confinement pour faire face à la
pandémie
notre peuple souffre la maladie frappe
avec plus de 91 mille morts et des
milliers d'hospitalisations frappe
socialement la barre de 10 millions de
pauvres a été franchi elle fera
psychologiquement particulièrement notre
jeunesse
ce matin le conseil de défense a décidé
de nouvelles mesures elles devons être à
la hauteur de la nouvelle dégradation de
la situation dans nos hôpitaux en ile de
france comme dans de nombreuses régions
la situation dans le service de
réanimation est dramatique car il n'y a
plus de lits pour accueillir des
patients en phase critique des malades
sur transféré mais les médecins le
disent
la vague est trop forte et l' annonce de
transfert ne suffira pas à l'endiguer
monsieur le premier ministre pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas ouvert de lits de
réanimation vous avez déclaré près des
territoires mans il ne suffit pas
d'acheter des lits chez ikea pour ouvrir
des places en or et à hyères soit vous
affirmiez on ne peut pas créer des lits
de réanimation des lits supplémentaires
d'un claquement de droit de doigts
monsieur le premier ministre le temps ne
s'est pas suspendu en un an
avec d'autres nous demandons depuis mars
2020 un changement radical de politique
de santé publique
rompant avec les lois du marché le 27
août monsieur le ministre de la santé a
annoncé que si la situation le nécessite
douze mille lits de réanimation pourront
être disponibles
où sont ils ces lits monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur premier ministre notre
peuple est las de ces vaines promesses
il constate l'affaiblissement de notre
système de santé public et la perte de
souveraineté
sanitaire puisque nous n'avons pas
encore produit d'autres vaccins masques
desk huiliers vaccin notre destin nous
échappe
monsieur le premier ministre donc quel
choix allez vous effectuer pour ouvrir
en urgence dans les jours à venir des
lits de réanimation et allez vous
prendre des dispositions pour sortir les
vaccins de la logique du marché
en levant les brevets et pour accélérer
considérablement la réalisation et la
production d'un vaccin français pour
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre la parole monsieur le
président du sénat mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs madame la présente à sacy
d'abord permettez moi monsieur le
président du sénat au nom du
gouvernement de vous remercier de
l'hommage que vous avez bien voulu un
cette date anniversaire rendre au
personnel soignante qui ont de temps et
qui donne tant pour notre pays qui sont
effectivement en première ligne qui sont
fatigués mais qui je le constate très
régulièrement vous le savez en me
rendant aussi souvent que possible
auprès d'eux dans les établissements de
santé sont toujours là et ne désarment
pas vous me posez madame la présidente
une question qui revient régulièrement
sur les lits de réanimation
j'ai déjà répondu plusieurs fois je vais
donc la répétition étant à la base à
pédagogie revenir une nouvelle fois sur
ce sujet devant vous de deux manières la
première la gestion de l'épidémie au
plan spitalier nous disposons en france
lit de réanimation et celi merci de le
rappeler
ce sont d'abord des personnels hautement
spécialisés qui ça n'occupe des médecins
des anesthésistes réanimateurs des
infirmières spécialisées tout ça vous le
savez de la même façon que vous savez
parfaitement
que pour former un médecin anesthésiste
réanimateur ou une infirmière
spécialisée
il faut de nombreuses années il faut de
nombreuses années bien et donc il ne
serait pas raisonnable de laisser
accroire qu'on peut ainsi mois ou un an
ferme et former des personnels aussi
spécialisés mais enfin tout bas donc que
faisons-nous depuis le début de la crise
nous reconverti sont d'autres lits en
mobilisant d'autres personnels
hospitaliers pour accroître nos
capacités d'accueil et c'est ce qui se
passe depuis le début je voudrais rendre
un hommage appuyé sur les progrès qui
sur ce registre ont été réalisés dans la
gestion des lits hospitaliers progrès
thérapeutique d'abord qui ont permis de
réduire les durées séjour progrès qui
ont permis de laisser ce qui n'était pas
le cas dans la première vague des
malades rue le prude matin chez eux en
eux les hospitaliser qu'en dernier
recours progrès qui ont permis de placer
des malades qui dans la première vague
était resté dans les lits de réanimation
dans d'autres lits évidemment lorsque la
pression épidémiques augmente et c'est
le cas cela entraîne et c'est la
conséquence de ce que je viens de vous
décrire des déprogrammations des
transferts de malades et de patients
quand cela est possible mais tout est
mis en oeuvre pour augmenter dans les
proportions qui ont été indiquées les il
vaudrait mieux parler mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs de capacité
d'accueil des malades à l'hôpital des
patients gravement atteints de la
qu'ovide il y a derrière ça et j'en
termine les questions structurelles
comment réarmer notre système de santé
autrement dit quels enseignements
quels enseignements tirer en août cette
crise c'est important de se poser la
question en est un an
et je voudrais dire au sénat qu on
aurait pu attendre la fin de la crise
pour le faire on ne l'a pas fait ça
s'appelle le ségur de la santé ça
s'appelle le set
9 y'a rien dedans 9 milliards et demi
d'euros comment pouvez-vous dire y'a
rien dedans
comment pouvez vous dire ça voulez-vous
que je rappelle le niveau de l'andam
depuis dix ans voulez vous je le
rappelle
bon je viens d'annoncer je viens
d'annoncer 19 il ya pour le volet
investissement
madame la présidente et c'est
extrêmement important moi qui ai connu
et j'en suis fière les plan hôpital 2007
et hôpital 2012
c'est 50% de plus que ces deux plans
réuni que vous allez que nous allons que
la nation engagée au bénéfice du service
santé et c'est justice et enfin madame
la présidente
là aussi vous avez parlé à juste titre
de la recherche d innovation en santé
oui ça fait 30 ans accumuler de retard
que nous payons aujourd'hui
eh bien nous allons vous le savez on a
commencé de faire ré investir aussi ce
sera le troisième volet du ségur
donc nous sommes pleinement mobilisés au
soutien des établissements hospitaliers
et des personnels pour faire face à la
résurgence de la pandémie en même temps
que nous travaillons à son renforcement
et à sa transformation structurelle
la parole est au président georges
patient pour le gros du rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant vous avez la parole le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues la
crise sanitaire que nous traversons a
révélé les fragilités structurelles et
un besoin croissant d'infrastructures au
niveau de toutes les collectivités
celle ci guidés par des élus locaux
engagés sont naturellement les mieux à
même d'identifier et de répondre à ses
besoins et elle le démontre
quotidiennement sur le terrain il est
donc bien que pour la mise en oeuvre du
plan de relance
un modèle de coopération été mis en
place notamment avec les régions
concrétisée par un accord de méthode et
un accord de partenariat
c'est ainsi que sur les 100 milliards du
plan de relance sans territoriale
territorialisées
16 milliards d'euros dont l'utilisation
est piloté par des comités régionaux co
présidées par les préfets et les
présidents de région c'est le cas pour
la collectivité territoriales de guyane
avec laquelle a été signé ce lundi un
accord très attendu que je tiens à
saluer cet accord territorial de relance
pour la période 2021 2022 prévoit un
effort à parité de l'état et de la
guyane à hauteur de 250 millions d'euros
des crédits supplémentaires en plus de
ceux déjà octroyés c'est un accord qui
permettra d'accompagner les
collectivités de soutenir les plans
projets d'infrastructures je pense entre
autre pour les premières opérations a
répété confortement des berges du marché
municipal de grand santi à l'aménagement
de la liaison routière maripasoula
papaïchton et à divers autres opérations
concernant les collectivités locales
mais cet accord portent aussi sur le
développement économique
car il soutiendra des projets privés
notamment de production d'électricité
basée sur les énergies renouvelables des
projets de valorisation des produits
agricoles ou d'exploitation de nos
ressources naturelles
monsieur le ministre près de six mois
après l annonce de cette nouvelle
méthode de coopération entre l'état et
les régions
pouvez vous nous présenter un point
d'étape sur la mise en place de ces
accords de relance régionaux pouvez-nous
pouvez-vous nous également dire si le
gouvernement entend pérenniser cette
coopération avec les élus locaux
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole les communistes délégué en charge
des comptes publics monsieur olivier du
soft vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur passion vous avez souligné dans
votre question l'intérêt qu'il y a
organisé une véritable coopération entre
les élus locaux au premier rang desquels
les élus régionaux et l'état à travers
le gouvernement pour la mise en oeuvre
du plan de relance
un premier accord avait été conclu sous
l'égide du premier ministre au mois de
juillet dernier
pour acter les modalités de compensation
la cvae
dans le cadre de la réforme des impôts
de production qui relève du plan de
relance en question un accord de méthode
a été signé le 28 septembre permet au
gouvernement d'envisager un partenariat
avec toutes les régions et puisque vous
nous interroger sur le point d'étape je
suis à même de vous dire que nous avons
d'ores et déjà signé dix accords
régionaux de relance avec autant de
régions et que nous avons effectivement
signé un accord avec la guyane le 15
mars
il y a quelques jours pour un effort de
250 millions à parité entre l'état et la
région ce sont vous l'avez dit 16
milliards d'euros du plan de relance qui
sont ainsi co piloté par l'état et par
les régions à la fois au travers du plan
de relance mais aussi au travers des
contrats des contrats de plan état
région pour la période 2021 et 2027 avec
mes collègues du ministère de la
cohésion des territoires notamment
jacqueline gourault joël giraud ici
présent nous veillons associer
systématiquement les ait lieu à la mise
en oeuvre du plan de relance
les accords régionaux nous le permettent
une circulaire du premier ministre nous
permet aussi de signer des accords avec
des départements avec des métropoles et
un accord a notamment été signée avec la
métropole de nantes
je voudrais aussi saisir cette occasion
monsieur le président patients pour dire
que dans ce cadre là nous veillons avec
beaucoup d'attention sur le partenariat
entre le gouvernement et les
collectivités d'outre-mer
vous avez cité d'accord avec la guyane
vous savez que nous avons veillé à ce
que plus de 1 milliard et demi d'euros
du plan de relance puissent bénéficier
aux territoires d'outre-mer
je pense notamment à l'appel à projet
sur la rénovation thermique et
énergétique des bâtiments d'état et
puisque vous nous demander si nous
envisageons de continuer la réponse est
évidemment affirmative
nous étions ensemble avec le député 15,9
pour mettre en place les premiers
contrats de redressement des
collectivités ultramarines
à la suite des propositions de votre
rapport et nous continuerons ainsi sur
la voie de la contractualisation et la
coopération
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
patrick kanner
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
région du coeur
monsieur le président mes chapeaux
ministre mes chers collègues le 17 mars
2022 vent l'explosion inexorable de
l'épidémie le confinement été mise en
place après l'improbable premier tour
des élections municipales
un an après je commencerai mon propos
comme vous l'avez fait monsieur le
président larcher par une pensée pour
les 91 mille disparus les millions de
malades touchés par la commune les
innombrables françaises et français
fragilisé par cette année horribilis
il ya un an devant la situation
d'exception qui nous percuter les
hésitations les urgences les prises de
décisions contradictoires ou l'absence
de décision tout cela pouvait peut-être
peut-être faire l'objet d'une forme
d'indulgence mais aujourd'hui de
situation exceptionnelle en situation
exceptionnelle nous observons une
dégradation de la gouvernance de la
crise d'urgence en urgence c'est la
démocratie qui est déstabilisée et nos
libertés écornée quand allez vous enfin
monsieur le premier ministre
organiser la prise de décisions de
manière plus démocratique et plus
transparents sur le président mesdames
et messieurs sénateurs monsieur le
président patrick kanner je revendique
devant la haute assemblée
la parfaite transparence des décisions
de l'exécutif et de la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire
devant la représentation parlementaire
mais aussi devant l'ensemble du peuple
français le peuple français
d'abord parce que nous mettons désormais
en ligne toutes les données nationales
et territoriales sur la crise dispose de
l'ensemble des éléments y compris pour
se faire sa propre opinion
nous respectons ensuite me semble-t-il
très scrupuleusement les règles de
dévolution des pouvoirs et des
compétences applicables dans le cadre de
la gestion d'une crise sanitaire qui
nécessite que l'autorité exécutive
puissent prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent
tout en rendant compte de façon
régulière et diversifiée à la
représentation nationale et c'est je le
dis très tranquillement devant le sénat
ce que nous faisons par divers canaux y
compris cher président nous les avons
amélioré par la création d'un comité de
liaison entre l'exécutif et les
présidents de groupes parlementaires qui
c'est un hasard se réunira cet
après-midi même après la présente
session de questions au gouvernement
nous n'avons rien à cacher nous avons
tout à gagner à transparence surtout
dans cette épreuve collective que
traverse notre pays
chacun à la fin des fins doit exercer
ses responsabilités
la république est ainsi organisée et le
pouvoir exécutif prend les siennes
monsieur le président caennais
monsieur le premier ministre vous n'avez
pas convaincu vous l'imaginez et le
silence du maître du temps perdu devient
assourdissant
depuis un an le conseil de défense que
vous n'avez pas évoqués dont aucun
compte rendu des publics est devenue une
instance de décision service d'un
pouvoir de plus en plus vertical ce
conseil de défense au fonctionnement bon
qu'est risée et finalement un esquif
ballotté au gré des circonstances
je prendrai un exemple ce prêt ministre
assez éclairant tout le monde sait
maintenant que fin janvier
vous même et votre ministre de la santé
vous les confiner
finalement le président de la république
a décidé seul de faire le pari inverse
pas de débat parlementaire pas de
discussions organisé la parole du
président a suffi alors que cette
décision allait impacter toutes la suite
de notre stratégie sanitaire que nous
voyons aujourd'hui pour l'exécutif le
triptyque bfmtv gilet des ballons
d'essai dans les médias suffit à
organiser
délibération publique ce n'est pas comme
cela que la confiance si nécessaire pour
biner notre combat contre la maladie
peut se construire
monsieur le premier ministre alors que
de nouveaux choix difficiles sont encore
une fois devant nous merci merci de vous
appuyer sur le seul et légitime conseil
celui qui représente la nation le
parlement français
merci monsieur le président à faro
l'état le fric oled andriole pour le
gros du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chaque collègue la
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics
olivier dussopt pta les collectivités
territoriales en charge l'élimination
des déchets ménagers agissent dans un
contexte difficile du fait notamment du
dispositif législatif en place en effet
alors que les prestations relatives à ce
service sont facturés
proportionnellement au tonnage des
déchets produits les recettes sont
destinées à financer elles soient
proportionnels la surface des logements
assujettis soit 6 une redevance dont les
prélèvements sont difficiles soit sur
une taxe une redevance incitative qui
n'ont hélas que trop souvent
d'incitatifs que le nom dans ce contexte
les collectivités comme unique de leur
mieux afin d'éviter nos concitoyens qui
je vous le rappelle sont les premiers
acteurs du dispositif amul trier leurs
déchets de manière à atteindre les
objectifs environnementaux ambitieux
mais partagée qui sont fixés cependant
toute augmentation de la taxe de la
redevance est mal vécu par nos
concitoyens qui ne voient pas leurs
efforts récompensés affectant les plus
vertueux d'entre eux qui risquent
d'abord d'abandonner le tri
renchérissant de ce fait le coût de ce
service avait les dégâts sur
l'environnement que l'imaginent pour
tenter de mieux maîtriser ses coûts la
loi de finances 2010 9 a introduit une
baisse
tva à 5 5% applicable sur l'ensemble des
prestations de collecte séparée cette
baisse de tva s'applique à compter du
1er janvier de cette année mais sans
connaître précisément le périmètre
concerné elle viendra atténuer certains
la marge de la moulée de la tgap prévu
les prochaines années dont un gel ou un
lissage voir un abattement pour les
déchets ultimes soit de nature à mieux
accompagner les collectivités dans leurs
efforts ma question est donc monsieur le
ministre
envisagez-vous d'éditer un décret
précisant les prestations de concernés
par cette baisse de tva et dans
l'affirmative quand s'arrêtera-t-il
puisque les collectivités finalise
actuellement leur budget primitif 2021
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est aux musiques délégué chargé
des comptes publics monsieur shop
merci président nous interroger sur la
question la fiscalité des déchets
notamment la fiscalité du traitement des
déchets et le recyclage
vous avez eu raison de rappeler que les
débats autour de la loi de finances 2010
9 avaient été des débats approfondis
puisque l'objectif était de mettre en
cohérence cette fiscalité avec un
objectif qui est de faciliter le tri aux
dépens de l'incinération et de la mise
en décharge
c'est ainsi que le parlement a approuvé
par la loi de finances 2010 9 une
augmentation de la tarification liés à
la composante des déchets de la taxe
générale sur les activités polluantes
cela se traduit pour ainsi par un
surcoût pour les collectivités à hauteur
d'un peu plus de 90 millions 90 millions
d'euros pour l'année 2000 21 et jusqu'à
un tout petit peu plus de 200 millions
en 2025
mais nous avons souhaité atténuer ce
coût pour les collectivités avec la mise
en place d'une fiscalité plus incitative
sur la question du tri et de la collecte
des déchets et c'est la baisse de tva de
5 5%
l'objectif que nous avons est clairement
de faire en sorte que la mise en
décharge ou l'incinération sont plus
onéreuses que le tri et le recyclage des
déchets de manière à poursuivre nos
objectifs environnementaux
il se trouve aujourd'hui où quelques
difficultés dans l'application de ces
dispositions les ait lieu que vous avez
donc des faits le porte parole nous
indique que parfois avoir des
difficultés pour mieux cerner le
périmètre où mieux mettre en oeuvre les
modalités de baisse de la tva en
particulier vous nous interroger sur
deux points
le premier concerne le périmètre des
activités et des services éligibles à la
tva 5 5%
ce périmètre a été arrêtée précisément
par la loi de finances pour 2010 9
il ne nécessite pas de texte
d'application mais nous veillerons par
les instructions données aux services
parce que ce périmètre soit
intégralement respectés et parfaitement
appliqué il y a un travail que nous
menons et que l'émissaire de transition
écologique ainsi que ministère des
comptes publics mènent avec les
associations d'élus qui consiste à bien
déterminer ce qui relève de la tva 5 5%
lorsque des prestations sont liées aux
mêmes contrats et aux mêmes prestataires
mais relève d'une part du tri d'autre
part d'incinération ou la mise en
déchets et sur ceux des partage des
tâches au sein d'un même contrat et pour
un même prestataire
nous avons encore besoin de quelques
semaines de travail mais je ne manquerai
pas de tenir ces l'informer de la
manière dont nous pourrons le précisez
pas textes réglementaires ou pas la
doctrine merci et donner la parole
maintenant notre collègue paul toussaint
paris j pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoires la parole
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale le 25 janvier
dernier
votre ministère et dictait un arrêté
réformant le concours externes du capes
pour différentes matières dont la langue
corse
cette réforme une fois n'est pas coutume
décidé sans nulle concertation avec les
syndicats et les universitaires seller
hélas un recul historique et
scientifique ravageur à maints égards et
porter une fois de plus atteinte aux
langues régionales à revers de
l'histoire donc après la réforme des
lecteurs du bac ou les coefficients des
langues régionales furent raboter
décourageant des armées d'élèves et de
futurs locuteurs cette fois ci c'est à
l'enseignement même du corps ce que vous
en preniez en inversant les coefficients
de notation les faisant passer de 7 à 4
pour la langue corse et de 4 à 8 pour le
français en nous proposant un capes au
rabais vous amis liés trente années
d'efforts et de reconnaissance triste
ironie monsieur le ministre que celle de
simal réussir la promotion des langues
régionales en transformant un capes
monovalent de langue corse en capes de
français option corse
suite au vote de l'assemblée le corps ce
contre cette réforme à la forte
mobilisation des élus de terrain des
syndicats des étudiants de l'université
et du jury du capes il semblerait que
votre ministère et finit par réaliser
les dommages collatéraux qu'implique est
ce votre réforme ce matin même
madame la rectrice de l'académie de
corse affirmé que votre ministère qui
avait jusque là fait l'économie d'un
travail important et techniques sur les
modalités d'organisation du concours
reverrait sa copie concernant le capes
de corse afin d'en préserver les
exigences et les attendus monsieur le
ministre nous confirmez vous que votre
ministère reviendra bien sûr l'erreur
historique que porte en lui l'arrêté du
25 janvier dernier je vous remercie
on va avoir la parole et au belize de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports monsieur blanc coeur de la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je commence par la
fin tout de suite je vais vous donner
satisfaction
j'aimerais du coup que ce soit
enregistré parce que ce que je constate
en ces matières c'est que souvent même
quand on donne satisfaction
on fait semblant de croire que l'on n'a
pas donné satisfaction donc je vous le
dis tout de suite je vais vous donner
satisfaction
d'abord premièrement si on est sur le
plan des principes j'ai reconnu à
maintes reprises devant la haute
assemblée
ce que dit tout simplement la
constitution c'est-à-dire les langues
régionales font partie du patrimoine de
la france
donc oui nous encourageons
l'apprentissage des langues régionales
et personne ne peut chercher à faire
croire le contraire dans un cadre
national
évidemment bien précis et ce cadre
évolue en permanence pour encourager
l'enseignement des langues régionales
je donne juste quelques chiffres qui
valent pour les langues régionales 514
professeurs sont titulaires du capes 170
mille élèves apprennent une langue
régionale aujourd'hui et nous nous
attachons sans arrêt à faire progresser
ce chiffre
vous avez dit par exemple que la réforme
du baccalauréat pouvait être contre les
langues régionales
grâce à la réforme du baccalauréat on
peut prendre une langue régionale en
enseignement de spécialité
ça signifie quatre heures en première 6
heures en terminale est évidemment ceux
ci n'existait pas auparavant
bien sûr on a aussi stimulé la demande
des élèves c'est le cas en corse
comme vous le savez nous avons jusqu'à
95 % des élèves qui font du corse en
sixième alors ça prendra du temps mais
je vais directement à votre question oui
nous faisons évoluer le capes de corse
pour aller dans le sens que vous
souhaitez c'est à dire qu'il est normal
que le coefficient augmente
ce coefficient était réglée à partir de
des règles valables pour l'ensemble des
capes on va l'adapter à la situation des
langues régionales
et donc ce que nous allons faire comme
l'a dit la rectrice ce matin et je
confirme complètement ses propos c'est
d'arriver à ce qu'il y ait huit un
coefficient de 8 sur 12 de matières
passé en langue corse c'est donc
davantage que la précédente version du
capes et c'est donc incontestablement un
progrès dans le sens que vous souhaitiez
je vous remercie
merci je vais donner la parole heures
l'autre collègue dany n'a pas omis des
agents pour le groupe les indépendants
et publique et territoires la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
attirer votre attention sur une
situation paradoxale qui est digne de
figurer dans l'un des plus grands
chefs-d'oeuvre de franz kafka ou
l'absurdité de certaines règles
administratives ce fait la meilleur
ennemi de la liberté d'entreprendre
nous sommes en pleine crise sanitaire
les salles de concerts sont fermées et
les artistes
assigné à résidence la vie culturelle
pourrait perdurer de façon
dématérialisée
mais les collectivités territoriales et
les associations qui organisent des
concerts de façon occasionnelle ne
peuvent plus passer par l'intermédiaire
du guichet unique du spectacle
occasionnels dit le guso ce dispositif
permet en temps normal en effet de
simplifier les démarches administratives
mais ne s'applique qu'aux
représentations en direct à titre
d'exemple orchestre symphonique de
l'aube qui est produit et financé par le
département ne peut plus recevoir son
public en raison de la crise sanitaire
dans l'attenté d'une réouverture des
salles
un accord a été passé avec une chaîne de
télévision locale pour enregistrer puis
rediffusé les concerts avec une chaîne
de télévision auprès du public et
permettre ainsi aux artistes de
continuer de travailler
le problème madame la ministre c'est
qu'aucune de ces prestations ne peut
être rémunérées par la collectivité via
le buso en raison d'un périmètre
d'application qui date de l'avant crise
qui a été certes légèrement remaniée
mais qui est toujours inadapté aux
concerts qui sont rediffusées
conséquence le département est contraint
de conclure en direct près de 60
contrats différents un parent musiciens
pour rémunérer ces artistes madame la
ministre je vous sais aller coûte et
pour sortir de ce cauchemar
bureaucratique
accepteriez vous détendre l'éligibilité
aux bizots à l'ensemble des concerts et
spectacles vivants avec ou sans public
diffusé en direct ou en différé sur des
chaînes télévisées via internet ou à la
radio
cette question est d'une grande
importance à la fois pour les musiciens
qui sont plongée en apnée dans une année
sabbatique force et qui se prolonge et
pour l'ensemble aussi de nos
compatriotes qui voient leur accès à la
culture entravé je vous remercie pour
la parole est à la ministre de la
culture on a muslim bachelot la parole
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice votre
question me permet de signaler
l'importance dans cette période
pandémique ont pris les captations et
l'action de l'état pour appuyer ces
captations à la fois par des crédits
massif pour permettre ces captations à
nouveau cette ligne de crédit vient
d'être abondée par le premier ministre
au niveau de 15 millions d'euros
également a été voté l'extension du
crédit d'impôt diot visuelle aux
captations et bien entendu la création
de la chaîne culture boxe a permis
véritablement de permettre des
diffusions de captation alors
effectivement il y a déjà un certain
nombre d'années le secrétaire d'état le
rentier tracé ce cas pourrait compléter
mon propos un guichet unique pour les
spectacles occasionnels a été créé ce
guichet unique n'est pas une prestation
supplémentaire pour les artistes
les artistes sont rémunérés et son
protégé socialement par les cotisations
et les rémunérations de leurs employeurs
ce guichet unique qui relève de pôle
emploi et non pas directement du
ministère de la culture permet donc de
simplifier les démarches des employeurs
la captation ne faisait pas partie des
prestations qu'ils pouvaient être qu'ils
pouvaient être entré dans le cadre du
guso il ya une simplification qui a été
apportée vous l'avez signalé c'est que
les captations effectué en direct et
retransmise en direct peuvent maintenant
bénéficier de cette simplification
destinée aux employeurs qui ne vient en
aucun cas impacter la rémunération et la
protection sociale qui est due au
salarié artistes qui sont employés dans
le cadre de ces captations mais moi je
suis très ouverte au fait qu'on puisse
étendre aux prestations en différé aux
captations différer les prestations
offertes par le guso et nous travaillons
d'ailleurs avec elisabeth bornes et
laurent pietra de sesca pour aller dans
le sens que vous souhaitez je vous
remercie de votre question madame le
sénat
triste la parole la parole est au
président bruno retailleau pour le
groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre
comme l'a très bien indiqué tout à
l'heure notre président du sénat gérard
larcher
ce jour anniversaire du premier
confinement marque aussi symboliquement
le surgissement de la pandémie dans
notre vie collective
aujourd'hui je ne veux pas dresser
l'inventaire de ce qui n'a pas marché
je veux vous parler d'une question
majeure parce que cette épidémie plus
qu'aucune autre crise a été pour notre
pays une épreuve de vérité
elle a révélé nos faiblesses et la
dévoiler un énorme paradoxe du côté
lumineux du côté lumineux tant
d'abnégation tant de dévouement
du côté du lumineux une réserve
d'humanité du côté obscur sombre des
manquements graves à nos devoir
d'humanité nous avons enfermés dans leur
solitude nos aînés nous avons parfois
dans le iie codé ehpad ou des hôpitaux
derrière les portes closes laisser
mourir seul loin de leurs proches des
femmes et des hommes
coupé de toute affection ce virus soyez
nous arracher des vies il nous a peut
être aussi arraché une victoire sa
victoire
c'est notre défaite c'est une terrible
défaite une défaite contre la
civilisation contre toutes ces anti
gones qui réclament que soit appliquée
les lois non écrites pour la dignité
humaine
je le pense je le premier ministre je
n'accuse absolument personne
simplement je veux savoir quelles sont
les leçons que vous premier ministre de
la france vous en tirer pour l'avenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le président mesdames et messieurs les
les sénateurs monsieur le présent
retailleau vous nous avez fait une
description que je peux partager des
dégâts massifs que cet ennemi invisible
a causé non seulement dans nos chers
mais aussi dans nos valeurs depuis
maintenant une année qu'il est arrivé
sur notre territoire est hélas avec des
mutations avec des évolutions
il ne l'a pas encore quitté 91000 196
morts c'est le nombre de victimes
dénombrées
hier depuis le début d'un pandémie hier
encore 320 personnes sont décédées dako
vide en france je pense bien sûr quand
on voit leur famille je pense aussi à
tous ces malades qui ont développé des
formes graves
quand elle a survécu mais qui continue à
porter des stigmates de longue durée qui
affecteront durablement leur ville et ne
parlons pas cher président des dégâts
psychologiques des conséquences
économiques et sociales qui comme
toujours sont affectés n'est plus
fragiles et les plus précaires de nos
concitoyens
vous avez fait allusion en particulier
je crois aux résidents des ehpad qui ont
pesé un tribut particulièrement lourd à
cette pandémie
je le rappelle il représente 1%
la population française et un tiers des
décès constatés raison pour laquelle
raison pour laquelle nous avons fait le
choix de commencer à les protéger à les
vacciner c'est fait
ils sont quasiment tous aujourd'hui 88 %
89% des résidents des ehpad ont été
vaccinées ce qui nous permet ce qui nous
permet de répondre à une autre
difficulté souligné par la crise
c'est-à-dire le droit de les accompagner
le droit de leur famille à leur rendre
visite
le droit à leur donner la vie décente
qu'il mérite dans des circonstances
dramatiques de la même manière monsieur
pédant et le sénat le sait le
gouvernement parlement n'a jamais hésité
à déployer pour tous les secteurs en
souffrance de notre société et de notre
économie des moyens c'est le fameux quoi
qu'il en coûte pour atténuer les
souffrances matériel d'abord et
psychique de nos concitoyens nous allons
pour achever de répondre à votre
question il faudrait l après-midi
tellement elle est vaste cher président
nous allons et nous avons bien
l'intention de continuer dans cette voie
tant que nous n'aurons pas vaincu ce
virus et je vous le dis mesdames et
messieurs et 7 heures monsieur le
président la vie la vie sera la plus
forte
nous vaincrons tous ensemble ce virus
nous mettrons un terme à cette tragédie
monsieur le président euros toyo
bien sûr monsieur le premier ministre
nous devons mener ce combat pour la vie
j'ai voulu simplement plaidé non
seulement pour ceux qui étaient dans les
eaux des ehpad mais aussi dans ses
chambres d'hôpitaux qui sont leur seul
j'ai voulu plaider pour leurs familles
qui ont été privés du rite de l'adieu et
pour ces familles le deuil est et vous
le savez très très difficile je pense
que on a voulu sans doute de bonne foi
protéger la vie mais on a réduit
l'existence à sa seule dimension
matérielle en coupant ses personnes
âgées et ces malades du lien affectif de
leur famille on les a aussi coupé de
leur raison de vivre vous voyez parce
que pour eux cette affection et cet
amour c'est ce qui leur rappelle que
pour décor leur corps épuisé par le
grand âge ils sont autre chose je pense
pour terminer qu'une civilisation peut
mourir de la guerre peut mourir de la
dénatalité mais qu'elle peut aussi et
plus sûrement encore mourir de l'oubli
de ce principe même essentiel qui la
constituent
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au président vincent
delahaye pour le groupe de l'union
centriste monsieur le président merci le
seul président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues mais
question s'adresse au ministre chargé
des comptes publics
demain la commission sur l'avenir des
finances publiques présidée par notre
ancien estimé collègue jean arthuis va
remettre ses conclusions au premier
ministre sa mission était de plancher
sur le remboursement de la dette
qu'ovide comment comment la traiter
connaissant le sérieux expertise de jean
arthuis
nous devinons qui ne sera pas question
de l'annulation de la dette
une idée saugrenue et dangereuse qui en
effrayant les investisseurs nous
aliénerait immédiatement toute capacité
d'emprunt pour le futur et nous
exposerait à une forte remontée des taux
d'intérêt comme il n'y a pas d'argent
magique
il nous faudra bien rembourser ce qui
met ce qui amène un certain nombre de
questions
la première c'est quelle est la facture
de la gestion de la crise sanitaire
le montant qu'il faudra rembourser le
gouvernement envisage-t-il de cantonner
la tête qu'au vide ce qui serait selon
moi tout sauf une bonne idée enfin
monsieur le ministre
envisagez vous de sortir dès 2021 du
quoi qu'il en coûte
comme vous l'avait annoncé où comptez
vous attendre 2022
après les élections présidentielles pour
vous répondre
la parole est au ministre délégué en
charge des comptes publics monsieur
olivier dussopt merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président de l'est
vous nous interroger sur le rapport que
la commission présidée par jean arthuis
va remettre très prochainement premier
ministre comprenez que je ne présiderai
pas du contenu du rapport
je peux simplement saluer la qualité et
la méthode du travail de la commission
qui a beaucoup entendu vous positionner
et j'aime toute confiance à la fois dans
son indépendance de plumes mais aussi
dans la qualité des propositions qui
nous seront portées que nous examinerons
avec la plus grande attention
il y a plusieurs questions dans votre
intervention la première concerne le
coût de la crise nous estimons qu'en
2020 entre les pertes de recettes et il
y pense que nous avons engagées pour
faire face à la crise que ce soit pour
l'état en termes de dépenses ou pour la
sécurité sociale en pertes de recettes
liées à la baisse de l'activité
le coût de la crise peut être estimée
autour de 160 à 170 milliards d'euros ce
chiffre n'est pas définitif puisque nous
sommes encore dans une crise épidémique
est une crise sanitaire
et c'est parce que nous sommes encore
dans la crise épidémique est dans la
crise sanitaire que nous ne pouvons pas
répondre à la date de la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte
je répète et je soutiens que cette
épidémie dont nous espérons tous qu'elle
soit une parenthèse devra se refermer et
quand même temps que la parenthèse
épidémique la parenthèse du quoi qu'il
en coûte devra aussi se fermer pour
retrouver un niveau plus soutenable de
dépenses publiques
c'est d'autant plus important que nous
sommes entrés dans la crise avec une
dette plus importante que beaucoup de
nos partenaires européens et que nous
avons besoin de rétablir progressivement
de comptes publics pour résorber
dette cette sortie de crise et cette
volonté de relancer l'économie devra
aussi être évoquée avec les partenaires
sociaux et le premier ministre a eu
l'occasion lors la conférence du
dialogue social d'inscrire la sortie de
crise à l'ordre du jour gevrey enfin
terminée mais c'est le président de
l'aïe en soulignant un point sur
lesquels je vous rejoins et je sais que
nous rejoignons les conclusions de la
commission arthuis pour avoir échangé
avec beaucoup d'entre eux c'est la
question de la gestion de la dette
les cantonnements peut-être une solution
qui n'efface pas la dette mais il a une
solution qui n'existe pas c'est
l'annulation l'annulation la seule
annulation possible c'est celle de la
crédibilité de la france et la france ne
fera pas défaut
elle ne l'a pas fait depuis plus de 200
ans nous tiendrons l'intégralité des
engagements parce que nous tenons nos
engagements nous pouvons faire face à la
crise et parce que nous tenons nos
engagements nous sommes en capacité de
nous appuyer sur les marchés pour
financer justement les mesures d'urgence
et les mesures de relance que nous avons
évoqués très rapidement nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir devant vous nous
croiserons les travaux de la commission
a fui avec ceux des parlementaires je
pense notamment à la proposition de loi
organique déposée par laurence lamarque
à eric woerth
et c'est en ce sens que je crois que
nous pourrons construire une trajectoire
de redressement progressif de nos
finances publiques
[Musique]
si monsieur le ministre pour vos
réponses précises c'est vrai que le coût
de la gestion de la crise n'est pas
terminée donc je pense qu'elle sera
supérieure à 170 milliards notre crainte
c'est de voir des contributions qui ont
été annoncés à l'origine comme
provisoire comme la crds mais finalement
devenir presque définitive j'allais dire
éternel mais je n'espère pas mais en
tout cas elles ont déjà été prorogé et
c'est vrai qu' il serait dommageable
pour nos concitoyens que on propose
encore ce genre de contribution
merci nous suivrons avec attention vos
décisions et les décisions du
gouvernement en matière de totalement
opa de cantonnement de cette dette
merci la parole est à notre collègue
olivier paccaud pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
vendredi 5 mars se chauffe au ministre
vous êtes rendu à beauvais
à la suite de plusieurs soirées de
violences urbaines vous avez été
accueillis par le maire caroline cayeux
par le député olivier dassault dont ce
fut une des dernières sorties
quelques voyous ont défié les autorités
parce que celle ci avait s'étaient
attaqués à leur trafic des guets-apens
était organisée pour piéger les
policiers avec les techniques
traditionnelles les tirs de mortiers les
feux de poubelles les barricades
face à cette délinquance des renforts
policiers ont été annoncées tant mieux
mais dans la garde-robe de maria n'y a
pas que l'uniforme du policier aussi la
toge du magistrat monsieur le premier
ministre et à beauvais
vous avez deux façons martial annoncé
rien ne restera impuni
ce sont vos mots lundi 8 mars les
premières sanctions sont tombées
le parquet avait requis 18 à 36 mois de
prison ferme pour quatre prévenus
aucun d'entre eux aucun d'entre eux
n'est sous les barreaux deux ont été
condamnés à 8 et 6 mois de prison ferme
l'un des deux avait quand même il faut
le dire il en était à sa 19e
condamnation
le procureur a fait appel ma question
elle est simple monsieur le ministre
ne pensez-vous pas que pour assurer
l'effectivité de la sanction pénale
le rétablissement des peines plancher
soit la bonne solution
pour vous répondre la parole est
monsieur le garde des sceaux les peines
planchers monsieur le sénateur vous les
avez voté mais elles n'ont eu aucun
effet strictement aucun et si l'on veut
comparer puisque cette question du
laxisme revient comme une ancienne dans
votre bouche
la réalité c'est que les peines n'ont
jamais été aussi durs ce que vous
évoquez c'est l'exécution des peines et
sur les peines
on va dire une chose très très
simplement parce que vous semblez ne pas
vous en souvenir quand ça vous arrange
le garde des sceaux en réalité sur les
peines il ne peut pas intervenir parce
que les juges de notre pays monsieur le
sénateur ils sont indépendants et dans
toutes les grandes démocraties
il n'est pas possible au pouvoir
exécutif d'intervenir sur le quantum
d'une peine là où le garde des sceaux
peut intervenir
c'est sur la célérité de la justice et
nous avons fait et nous ferons encore
beaucoup de choses là on le garde des
sceaux peut intervenir
c'est sur la systématisation de la
réponse pénale et qu'il me soit permis
de vous dire que le taux de réponse
pénale est de l'ordre de 92 % dans notre
pays et que le taux d'exécution des
peines contrairement à ce que certains
peuvent raconter à des fins
électoralistes et supérieur dans notre
pays à 81 12 % la parole est à monsieur
olivier plus preco
oui merci pour votre réponse enflammée
rien ne restera impuni c'est ce que vous
avez dit mea culpa
les quatre prévenus ont écopé de 135
euros d'amendé pour violation du coureur
mais sans c'est vous qui avez parlé de
laxisme je laisserai le dernier mot le
mot de la sagesse un petit peu de
décence le mot de la sagesse à sénèque
on doit punir non pour punir mais pour
prévenir
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant peuvent la
présidente laurence rossignol
pour le gros socialistes écologistes et
républicains
merci monsieur le président nistre la
loi prévoit que le conseil des ministres
peut révoquer par décret un maire ou ses
adjoints
à chaque fois que cette prérogative a
été utilisée par le passé fort
heureusement assez rarement
il a été noté que les faits reprochés
privé l'élu de l'autorité morale
nécessaire à l'exercice de ses fonctions
le 17 février dernier l'ancien ministre
et actuel maire de draveil a été
condamné à cinq ans de prison dont trois
ferme pour viol agressions sexuelles en
réunion
il est d'ailleurs actuellement en prison
il est écroué à l'issue même de
l'audience
il refuse de démissionner il considère
qu'il peut tout à fait il est empêché
selon l'une et qui peut continuer
d'exercer son mandat et il joua monde
grâce à un pourvoi en cassation
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le premier
ministre que viols et agressions
sexuelles en réunion pourrait tout à
fait être qualifiée de fait privant les
luttes de temps et et morales
nécessaires pour ses fonctions vous avez
le pouvoir je réponds collègues vous
avez le pouvoir en conseil des ministres
de démettre ce mr qu'attendez vous pour
le faire c'est la noire c'est l'article
attendez à monsieur paul minnesota un
doute c'est d'articles de 29 22 16 du
code des collectivités territoriales
pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le garde des
sceaux
décidément les oppositions en demande
beaucoup à l'exécutif les oppositions
demande à l'exécutif d'intervenir dans
le cadre de décisions juridictionnelles
qui je le redis nous dit pas non c'est
lui qui je le redis dépendent
exclusivement exclusivement des
magistrats notre pays qui sont
indépendants quand on dirige les
magistrats et que l'on est membre de
l'exécutif
alors on n'est plus dans une démocratie
quant au reste madame la sénatrice vous
qui est respectueuse je le suppose de la
présomption d'innocence présomption
d'innocence mis en avant par madame
elisabeth guigou dans une loi
merveilleuse que vous connaissez
forcément il me semble que ce
justiciable un formé un pourvoi en
cassation que la décision dès lors n'est
pas définitive et qu'il se débrouille
avec sa conscience ou demandé à
l'exécutif d'intervenir là dedans mais
franchement quelle hérésie
madame la présidente laurence rossignol
ce que je demande à et déjà été fait à
plusieurs reprises deuxièmement je
n'aurais jamais cru que le gouvernement
envoie pour répondre à ma question
l'avocat de georges tron celui qui a
traité de menteuse
les victimes pendant tout le procès et
qui continue aujourd'hui les traiter de
menteuse en arguant de la présomption
d'innocence alors que vous avez été
condamné
la parole lors appel quand on ne me
prend pas à question pour d'effets
personnels je le rappelle à l'ensemble
des sénateurs
c'est un principe qu'il convient de
respecter
c'est le garde des sceaux c'est moi qui
y préside la parole et à daniel
grappiller pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il ya un
peu plus de 20 ans la vache folle a
frappé notre territoire a frappé à
traumatiser nos éleveurs et inquiéter
complètement nos consommateurs de là
découle est un certain nombre de mesures
qui ont été prises d'initiatives de
contraintes supplémentaires d'affichage
et puis plus dernièrement le sénat était
à l'initiative 2016 2017 sur un texte
que nous avons voté au niveau de la ppl
sur la compétitivité de l'agriculture ou
en tant que rapporteur nous avons jamais
présenté un amendement a été voté par
l'ensemble du groupe
l'ensemble des groupes pour permettre la
transparence est affiché l'étiquetage de
ce texte il a été repris au niveau de la
loi sapin 2 et il a été voté
là encore et le sénat non seulement la
voix relayant voter ici il a voté deux
résolutions européenne pour faire et
accompagner le gouvernement dans cette
démarche de cela il ya eu un certain
nombre de textes l'europe nous a donné l
expérimentation pour deux ans nous avons
eu des textes la loi et galim là le
texte sur la convention citoyenne qui
apportent des charges et des contraintes
supplémentaires et aujourd'hui conseil
d'état cass l'étiquetage
quelle est la réponse du gouvernement
pour neutre a pas même pas trahir les
éleveurs et apporter la transparence aux
consommateurs pour vous répondre à
l'appel
sow ministre délégué en charge des
comptes publics monsieur dussault vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mais si un
sénateur grémillet permettez moi d'abord
d'excuser l'absence de mon collègue
julien de normandie il est isolé
quelques jours en application des règles
sanitaires et m'a demandé de bien
vouloir vous répondre vous évoquez une
décision du conseil d'état du 10 mars
2021 qui a annulé le décret du 19 août
2016 du 24 décembre 2018 et du 27 mars
2020 qui précise qu'ils prévoyaient une
obligation de mention l'origine du lait
et du lait utilisé comme ingrédient sur
l'ensemble des emballages
je ne reviens pas sur l'utilité et la
pertinence de d'étiquetage vous l'avez
rappelé et le parlement au fil des
époques a renforcé ses obligations
d'étiquetage pour garantir la sécurité
des consommateurs
assurer une traçabilité et ainsi la
meilleure prévention possible
en conséquence de la décision du conseil
d'état
l'absence de mention sur les étiquettes
de l'origine sur les produits laitiers
ne pourra plus être sanctionnés
néanmoins la mention l'origine peut
toujours continuer à être indiquée mais
de façon volontaire par les producteurs
cette décision est la suite logique de
la décision de la cour de justice
européenne du 1er octobre dernier suite
à une plainte déposée par l'entreprise
lactalis contre les décrets que j'ai
cité plus haut vous devinez monsieur le
sénateur que le gouvernement ne peut pas
commenter une décision du conseil d'état
et que nous devons en prendre acte
si la con justice n'a pas jugé le décret
2016 illégal elle a conditionné au fait
que l'origine du produit devaient être
rendues obligatoires que sous certaines
conditions à savoir la nécessité
justifiée un lien entre l'origine ou la
provenance du lait vous demander
monsieur le sénateur quelle sera la
réponse du gouvernement pour ne pas
trahir les engagements des galets mon
collègue vient de normandie aura
l'occasion de faire très rapidement des
propositions tout particulièrement dans
le cadre de l'examen de la loi climat et
résilience de façon à garantir cette
possibilité d'étiquetage est trouvé avec
l'ensemble des parlementaires les voies
et les moyens d'avoir un étiquetage de
qualité et protecteur des consommateurs
je saisis l'occasion de votre question
pour préciser que pour ce qui concerne
l'origine des viandes autres produits
concernés aussi fortement par
l'étiquetage la décision du conseil
d'état ne fait pas tomber
l'obligation d'étiquetage
sur les viandes et les viandes entonnent
en tant qu'ingrédient dans les dents et
préemballés
nous veillerons bien évidemment est-ce
que c'est acquis sa préservé de même que
je viens de normandie travaillera pour
établir un certain nombre de
dispositions avec vous et avec un sens
des parlementaires monsieur le ministre
je ne suis pas là en train de commenter
une décision du conseil d'état
je suis simplement là en train de dire
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
tromper les consommateurs aujourd'hui
une somme en train de trahir les
producteurs nous leur apportons des
charges qui ne sont pas européennes
nous leur apportons des contraintes qui
ne sont pas européennes il ya une chose
qu'on m'a apprise je prends l'exemple
des circuits courts avec ce qui vient
d'être décidé
eh bien demain dans des circuits courts
on pourrait imaginer du lait venant de
pologne ou de roumanie j'ai rien contre
eux ils font partie européenne mais il
peut être au même niveau que du lait
provenant d'une ferme d'à côté et j'ai
appris une chose par le philippe seguin
avec qui j'ai des relations et ont des
vosges
philippe seguin m'a toujours rappeler
une chose daniel n'oublie jamais une
bonne idée il passe par le stade
minoritaires elle est née ici au sénat
l'étiquetage c'est ton travail qui la
porte qui permettra seul ton travail qui
permettra qu'elle soit le majoritaire
manifestement vous n'avez pas fait le
travail au niveau du gouvernement
l'europe va accorder concluant
d'expérimentation vous n'avez pas été
capable en quatre ans de concrétiser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est aux questeurs vincent
capo-canellas pour le groupe de l'union
centriste que la parole merci monsieur
le président ma question s'inscrit bien
sûr dans le contexte qui a été rappelé
tout à l'heure par le premier ministre
et par les différents orateurs à savoir
le besoin bien sûr de faire face aux cas
de contagion qui malheureusement se
développe encore plus en ce moment mais
aussi de préparer les conditions pour
permettre la reprise d'activité le
moment venu pour différents secteurs qui
sont aujourd'hui très largement touchés
et qu'ils sont en très grande difficulté
bien sûr il faut faire face au présent
mais nous devons d'ores et déjà allumé
quand même des lumières d'espoir pour
ces secteurs d'activité je voudrais
illustrer cette question en parlant du
secteur de l'événementiel professionnel
les foires et salons secteur fortement
touché il ya plus de quarante mille
salariés et plus de 400 mille salariés
indirects et on sait que malgré les
aides du gouvernement qui couvre à peu
près la moitié des charges fixes
il ya 70 à 80 % de perte d'activité pour
ce secteur aujourd'hui on considère que
50 % des entreprises sont au bord de la
faillite
l'avenir est donc largement compromis et
nous manquons de perspectives alors que
d'autres pays européens ont annoncé une
ambition de réouverture avec d'ores et
déjà un planning dans le domaine
culturel
monsieur le ministre de l'économie dès
annonces ont été faites sur des
possibilités de faire des tests sur des
possibilités d'ouverture partielle et on
sait que les bras au ciel du secteur de
l'événementiel sont prêts aujourd'hui à
une reprise graduelle sont prêts à des
salons limiter à des petits formats et
son trait aussi à des salons limité aux
zones géographiques y sont les moins
touchées
ces expérimentations y êtes vous prêts
et êtes-vous prêts également à vous
saisir du pass alité à qui a été évoquée
jusqu'au président là jusque par le
président de république et qui est
encore aujourd'hui promu semble-t-il par
la commission européenne
intel 16 passes sanitaires et serait
évidemment l'occasion de permettre une
reprise graduelle de l'activité dans ces
secteurs là mais aussi dans ceux du
tourisme du transport aérien ou de
l'hôtellerie
restauration donc ma question est simple
compte en faire le gouvernement pour
soutenir ce secteur d'activité souhaité
se saisir du pass aérien pour
déverrouiller l'économie dans les
secteurs qui sont aujourd'hui à l'arrêt
monsieur le ministre délégué en charge
des comptes publics ressort
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur qu'avocats nous appeler
l'attention du gouvernement sur les
secteurs d'activités notamment
l'événementiel ou l'aéronautique
qui sont les plus touchés et qu'ils
risquent d'être les plus touchés
durablement par la crise épidémique que
nous traversons vous me permettrez
monsieur le sénateur de ne pas entrer
dans des considérations d'ordre
sanitaire ou liés à des problématiques
ou des thématiques de circulation et de
règles européennes c'est la relève de la
compétence d'autres de mes collègues du
gouvernement et de l'autorité du premier
ministre qui a d'at t qui prend les
décisions en fonction de l'évolution de
la situation épidémique
je vais simplement souligner deux choses
la première c'est que nous avons veillé
avec bruno le maire à ce que
l'intégralité des acteurs du secteur
événementiel en particulier soient
éligibles au dispositif devait être que
nous avons mises en place l'activité
partielle laquelle le fonds solidarité
bien évidemment et les exonérations de
cotisations nous avons veillé aussi
peut-être yat-il encore quelques
améliorations apportées à ce que
l'ensemble des acteurs soient concernés
par les dispositifs et je pense
notamment aux salariés qui parfois
peuvent connaître des conditions de vie
précaires avec la multiplication de
contrats courts on parle parfois de
permis temps et il a été acté des aides
spécifiques à hauteur de 900 euros
minimum garanti par mois mises en oeuvre
par ma collègue denis du travail nous
avons veillé à ce que l'ensemble de ces
dispositifs sont activés et nous avons
eu l'occasion d'annoncer cette semaine
que nous renforçons la prise en charge
des coûts fixes avec un décret qui a été
acceptée par la commission européenne
dans les entreprises ayant des chiffres
d'affaires importants et qui sont
caractérisés par des coûts fixes
extrêmement lourd il se pose aussi la
question de la sortie de crise la
reprise d'activité là aussi sans pouvoir
préjuger des dates de reprise d'activité
mon collègue alain griset
échangé depuis le début de cette semaine
avec l'ensemble des acteurs de la
filière et notamment les filières vous
avez évoqué pouvoir comment imaginer des
reprises d'activités ce cas initié
roselyne bachelot ministre de la culture
en matière d'expérimentation dans le
domaine culturel sera extrêmement
précieux pour accompagner et nourrir
d'idées les conditions de reprise
d'activité dans le secteur événementiel
dans le secteur aéronautique
l'essentiel est que les acteurs soient
prêts et c'est ce à quoi nous
travaillons
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue patrick chaize pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
numérique ce n'est pas que du virtuel
dans une société qui se numérise
toujours plus vite
la résilience informatique de toute
l'économie comme de nos services publics
devient chaque jour plus essentiel il ya
bien entendu la question de la pérennité
de nos réseaux c'est la souveraineté
numérique ou de l'hébergement des
données mais aussi la protection contre
le piratage et les attaques toujours
plus nombreuses il est pourtant un
risque que nous aurons peut-être
sous-estimé lincendie des serveurs de vh
à strasbourg dans la nuit du 9 au 10
mars vient de mettre en évidence cet
événement a montré que les atteintes
physiques représentait aussi une menace
bien réelle sur le service virtuel
ces risques appelle à la nécessaire
vigilance autour de tous nos outils
informatiques 3,5 millions de sites web
ont été impactés par l' incendie des
serveurs de vh des sites d'entreprises
de collectivités et même gouvernementaux
sont concernées y compris ceux de la
santé pourtant hautement stratégique
en ces temps de crise sanitaire nous
avons découvert à cette occasion que
certains services en ligne où certaines
bases de données n'étaient pardon des
pires qu'ils étaient redondée dans une
autre salle du même datacenter et
n'essayez pas de prévenir le régulateur
sur l'atteinte des réseaux de
communication sur le site j'alerte
l'arcep lui même toujours inaccessible
une semaine après cet incendie
l'absence d'euros donnant ce réel des
données des sites et applications d'une
part et de plans de reprise d'activité
d'autre part n'est assurément pas isolé
notez les services publics les données
de nos territoires comme de nos
concitoyens ne mérite-t-il pas de coffre
fort numérique plus sur le numérique est
une chance
c'est aussi un risque il est de notre
responsabilité que nos sociétés ne soit
plus ce colosse aux pieds de silicium
alors monsieur le ministre quelles
actions comptez vous mettre en oeuvre
pour garantir que pareil accident ne
provoque plus arrêt même temporaire de
nos services les plus essentiels et que
l'informatique en nuage ne partent plus
en fumée la parole est toujours à
olivier du choc il est légué aux
recherches des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président messieurs
sénateurs chaise votre question et
surtout le sinistre qui a connu ovh dans
l'est invite évidemment à la prudence
mais invite à revoir l'intégralité des
conditions dans lesquelles les données
notamment les données des services
publics de l'état mais aussi des
collectivités sont conservés je vais
d'abord vous rassurer mon collègue
cédric immédiatement informé de ce
sinistre a pris tous les renseignements
et toutes les précautions nécessaires
d'abord vous rassurer en indiquant que
pour les principales données de l'état
et pour les réseaux les plus
stratégiques de l'état nous gardons une
capacité à opérer directement et le
recours à des solutions de stockage en
cloud ne nous a pas empêchés de
préserver de dupliquer un certain nombre
de données et faire en sorte que nos
bases de données sont parfaitement
protégés alors nous parlons l'ensemble
des services numériques du quotidien
fonctionne et nous n'avons pas connu au
sein du service de l'état
deux défauts majeurs après l'incendié au
vh tels que nous aurions pu le craindre
cela démontre à la fois le niveau de
préparation et de protection des
services de l'état mais je le répète cet
incendie doit permettre une revue de
l'ensemble des paramètres doit permettre
de faire preuve de précaution et doit
aussi inciter l'ensemble des acteurs pas
seulement l'état à avoir des solutions
qui permettent une redondance des
données et ainsi une meilleure
protection
je voudrais aussi vous indiquez monsieur
le sénateur que nous devons accompagner
l'entreprise qui est concerné par ce
sinistre
cette entreprise a récemment intégré le
nex 40 cedrico a eu un contact je disais
lesquels en début de semaine c'est une
entreprise qui est une pépite française
qui compte aujourd'hui plus de 2500
salariés qui peut s'appuyer sur 32
datacenter nous les accompagnerons pour
la reprise de leur activité et pour
faire en sorte qu'elle puisse faire face
aux sinistres
nous pouvons aussi indiqué selon les
informations dont nous avons que la
stratégie de précaution et de
préservation des données fonctionne bien
aussi pour l'entreprise qui pas à pas
mais l'ensemble reste et si ses mains en
fonctionnement pour servir ses clients
et ainsi assurer ainsi son rôle de
prestataire l'alertent que nous avons
connue est importante nous devons y
veiller mais aujourd'hui je tiens à être
rassurant sur les conséquences que cela
aurait pu avoir sur les tailles sont
fonctions bien merci la parole et à
notre collègue jean-michel houlgate pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ceux qui analysent cette crise
sanitaire et son impact sur les
territoires s'accordent à dire que la
pandémie agit en accélérateur des
mutations en cours
or parmi ces mutations la dévitalisation
de nos territoires ruraux s'amplifie
l'un des exemples les plus emblématiques
en est le risque de disparition des
derniers commerces de proximité en
milieu rural et pour lesquelles les élus
se sont beaucoup mobilisés pour leur
maintien en amenant leur commune à
devenir propriétaire des murs ou en
accordant des exonérations
rappelons que l'une des particularités
de ces petits commerces tient au fait
que de multiples activités sont exercées
dans un même lieu avec un café proposant
parfois une restauration légère une
épicerie parfois un dépôt de pain ou de
gaz ils ont une viabilité économique
assez fragile basé sur la contribution
de chacune de ses activités
aussi la fermeture du fait de la crise
de la partie bar et de la partie
restauration qui par ailleurs ne
constitue pas l'activité principale et
n'entraîne pas une baisse du chiffre
d'affaires supérieur aux 50 %
nécessaires à loup
arthur des droits au fonds de solidarité
met en péril économique ces petits
commerces essentielles en milieu rural
parce que comme chacun le sait c'est la
marge sur ses activités bar restauration
qui est largement supérieure à celle des
autres activités qui fait vivre
l'entreprise sur le ministre devant
l'urgence le gouvernement envisage-t-il
soit un élargissement des conditions
mentionnées au décret du 8 février 2021
donnant accès au fonds de solidarité
pour ces petits commerces ou bien
envisage-t-il une mesure particulière de
soutien aux derniers commerces de
proximité en milieu rural afin d'éviter
un réel désastre mettant en péril la
vitalité de nos espaces ruraux pour à la
question merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur houlgate
vous avez tout dit dans votre question
en réalité il y a grand nombre de multi
commerce comme nous les appelons dont
l'activité peut être majoritairement une
activité qui ne fait pas l'objet d'une
mesure de restriction et donc il n'a pas
accès automatiquement au dispositif
d'aidé notamment le fonds de solidarité
alors même que l'activité considérée
comme minoritaire dans le chiffre
d'affaires est celle qui peut générer le
plus de marges donc le plus grande
capacité à vivre
nous avons le cas avec les faire beau
les fermes auberges avec les termes
restaurant nous avons le cas aussi avec
tout un ensemble de petits commerces
souvent logés dans des bâtiments qui
appartiennent aux communes et qui ont à
la fois une activité d'épicerie une
activité restauration mois encore une
activité de distribution de presse je
tiens compte ce que nous avons d'ores et
déjà apporté et ce sur quoi nous
travaillons
la première réponse que nous avons
apportées et de faire en sorte que à
chaque fois qu'un cas particulier nous
est soumis soumis à notre administration
nous fassions procédé
un examen au cas par cas de manière à
débloquer les situations
la deuxième réponse que nous avons
apportés si en fait que nous avons des
connectés l'éligibilité à une aide du
code ape dont sous lequel l'entreprise
est inscrit exerce son activité et ainsi
nous avons 14 % des bénéficiaires du
fonds de solidarité qui bénéficient du
fonds à leur club leur code ape
d'inscription ne relève pas de
l'éligibilité ou des secteurs et 100 et
110 parce que nous avons tenu compte de
l'activité majorité à exercer nous
devons aller un peu plus loin
nous ne sommes pas convaincus que
l'extension du fonds de solidarité soit
la solution car il aurait
malheureusement des effets d'aubaine
mais nous cherchons actuellement une
solution pour mieux couvrir ces
commerces dits de multi activités enfin
même si le sénateur notre question aussi
l'occasion pour moi de rappeler devant
le sénat aujourd'hui le fonds solidarité
permet depuis le début de la crise dd
plus de deux millions d'entreprises que
nous avons détester 17 milliards d'euros
à date que nous avons aussi procédé à
une quinzaine de modification du fonds
pour répondre aux imperfections qui
pouvaient présidé à sa création
nous continuons à travailler avec alain
griset bruno le maire pour être le plus
efficient possible et dans l'attenté
nous veillons à cet examen qui a parti
merci monsieur ministre ses réponses
mais la réalité est en danger et je dois
dire que je suis moi sans cesse
confronté par à part des maires qui me
font remarquer la fermeture de classe la
fermeture de perception
éventuellement donc des difficultés donc
sur l'accès numérique sur la couverture
sanitaire dont kylie a véritablement un
plan d'action sur nos espaces ruraux et
on peut rendre hommage aussi à vanik
berberian d'ailleurs qui sait qu'on qui
a bête qui ces combats qui a combattu
toute sa vie
justement en service dès au service des
espaces ruraux merci la parole est à
notre collègue joëlle garriaud-maylam
pour le groupe l'est républicain
ma question s'adresse au ministre des
affaires étrangères un parlement dissout
des morts par centaines des tortures des
milliers d'arrestations
la loi martiale proclamait la peine de
mort rétabli l'économie à l'arrêt la
famine qui s'installe les entrepôts les
ong et même les pagodes pillé par
l'armée c'est en birmanie le bilan
terrifiant du coup d'état du 1er février
tout ça parce que la junte militaire n'a
pas supporté qu'une femme
aung san suu kyi et son parti la lnd
gagne +2 83% des voix lors des dernières
législatives
aung san suu kyi est aujourd'hui au
secret même ses enfants n'ont aucune
nouvelle d'elle et la fuite en avant
continue la junte osant même à l'accusé
ainsi que le docteur saas représentent à
l'oeil nu de trahison et de corruption
avec un mandat d'arrêt international
tombée ce matin même contre ce dernier
face à cette dictature ni le mouvement
de désobéissance civile unis tous les
birmans de toutes classes sociales
religions et ethnies y compris bien sûr
l'héroïne gas monsieur le ministre
notre ambassade à rangoon fait un
travail remarquable que je tiens à
souligner mais il faut aujourd'hui aller
au delà des déclarations d'inquiétude ou
de condamnation les sanctions ciblées de
l'union européenne ne seront utiles que
si l on bloque toute la famille des
dirigeants dans leurs enfants de même
les birmans espère la reconnaissance par
la france du cerf ph le gouvernement
parallèle issu des urnes
la france est une responsabilité
historique elle se doit d'encourager le
valeureux peuple birman lutte contre une
dictature mafieuse
elle se doit de montrer au monde qu'elle
reste fidèle à ses valeurs de liberté de
droits de l'homme en entraînant les
autres pays à faire de même
monsieur le ministre comment convaincre
la zean la russie et la chine de sortir
de leur neutralité pour s'engager à nos
côtés et aux côtés des birmans et que
pouvez vous nous dire aujourd'hui du
dialogue avec ses airs ph pour mettre
fin à une guerre civile de plus en plus
meurtrière pour vous répondre la parole
est à franck rayé faire ministre en
charge du commerce extérieur monsieur le
ministre
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice garraud mais l'âme
jean yves le drian comme vous le savez a
été en contact avec un cas positif et
donc il est à l'isolément ou suivait de
très près la birmanie depuis longtemps
madame la sénatrice et vous avez raison
la situation est grave et la dégradation
s'accélère
rien que sur la journée du 14 mars ce
sont 70 morts qui ont été recensés en
birmanie comme vous le savez la france a
condamné bien évidemment le coup d'état
comme l'union européenne nous ne
reconnaissons pas la junte et les
discussions sont en cours technique à
bruxelles pour que lors du conseil des
affaires étrangères du 22 mars des
sanctions ciblant les celles et ceux qui
ont contribué
à ce coup d'état les dirigeants de ce
coup d'état puisse être prononcée
nous réfléchissons aussi à étendre ses
sanctions à certaines entités
économiques car rien doit être fait pour
continuer à donner de l'argent à l'armée
birmane dans ces moment si périlleux
vous pouvez compter bien évidemment sur
la détermination de la france à trouver
une solution à cette crise jean yves le
drian prend de nombreux contacts avec
ses homologues des pays que vous avez
évoqué des pays de la zone parce que je
crois que la zenn un rôle majeur à jouer
en la matière nous continuons également
à suivre de près toutes les ong qui
travaillent en birmanie nous continuons
notre aide humanitaire nous soutenons la
société civile parce que la situation
comme vous l'avez rappelé en birmanie
est très grave mais jean yves le drian
et toutes les équipes du quai d'orsay et
du gouvernement plus largement sous
l'autorité du premier ministre weil avec
beaucoup d'attention à ce qu'on puisse
sortir très rapidement de cette crise
majeure en birmanie je vous remercie
madame la sénatrice
merci la parole est notre collègue
philippe folliot pour le groupe de
l'union centriste de la parole merci le
seul président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues lundi
dernier l'ouverture de la billetterie
pour la coupe du monde de rugby de
france 2023 a été un succès considérable
en quelques heures la totalité des 310
1000e premier billet a été vendu avec
des pics à 1000 billets par minute
la france va avoir l'honneur
d'accueillir le troisième plus gros
événement sportif au monde
la coupe du monde de rugby et quelques
mois après le premier les jeux
olympiques c'est une grande chance pour
notre pays pour son rayonnement
mais aussi pour notre économie la seule
coupe du monde de rugby devrait attirer
600 mille visiteurs étrangers au fort
pouvoir d'achat
selon le comité d'organisation
l'événement pourrait rapporter 3,4
milliards d'euros à notre pays crédit
7000 emplois dont 3000 d'apprentis
accueillis au sein du comité
d'organisation et générer 119 millions
d'euros de taxes additionnelles
mais pour avoir lieu et se dérouler dans
de bonnes conditions
les grands événements sportifs exige une
préparation à la mesure de l'enjeu les
jeux olympiques en particulier réclame
eu d'importants investissements la
rénovation du grand palais par exemple
qui doit accueillir le judo et les
scream vient seulement de débuter
il faut encore construire le village et
la piscine olympique et les
infrastructures de transport ont pris un
retard considérable
monsieur le ministre de l'âge de
l'éducation de la jeunesse et des sports
quel a été l'impact de la crise
sanitaire sur la préparation de ces
grands événements sportifs
serons nous dans les temps en
particulier pour les jo et le japon a dû
décaler ses jeux olympiques d'un angle
ne risquons nous pas d'être contraint de
faire de même
monsieur lui dise de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et les sports
chez le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur folio d'abord merci de
souligner l'importance de ces grands
événements sportifs tout
particulièrement le championnat du monde
de rugby nous sommes évidemment tous
très attachés à ce qu'il s'organise bien
et fortement pour 2023
et de souligner que la france a un rôle
très particulier en la matière nous
avons rappelons le et chacun sait le
cours de l'année qui vient de s'écouler
montrer au monde entier une capacité de
résilience très forte en la matière
roland garros le tour de france autant
d'événements qui le vendée globe
autant d'événements qui sont de grands
événements sportifs internationaux et la
france est le pays qui a su les
maintenir ces grands événements sportifs
internationaux
malgré la crise on doit en être heureux
et féliciter ceux qui ont été capables
de cela
pour autant ce n'est pas simple pour
ceux qui organisent ces événements nous
il y a du avoir 40 % d'annulations 20%
de report et 40% d'organisation
d'événements sportifs internationaux
français au cours de l'année qui vient
de s'écouler
nous avons aussi aidé les organisateurs
de différentes façons avec le ministère
des affaires étrangères en particulier
pour permettre que des athlètes
internationaux puissent venir
nous avons aussi travaillé avec le
ministère de l'économie pour que les
organisateurs puissent bénéficier
et des soutiens deux hommes qui valent
pour tous les acteurs économiques mais
aussi avec des mesures particulières que
président de la république a décidé
lui-même je pense en particulier aux
compensations de billetterie pour plus
de 100 millions d'euros qui ont été
décidés il ya quelques mois pour
justement les organisateurs d'événements
sportifs
tout ceci fait que nous avons préserver
autant que possible la santé économique
des acteurs pour qu'ils puissent
continuer à agir et préparer des
événements sportifs futur comme par
exemple cette année le tour de france et
roland garros de nouveau s'agissant de
la préparation des jeux olympiques il ya
évidemment toute une série
d'inconvénients à la situation actuelle
comme vous le savez le comité olympique
et le comité donc paris 2024 travaille à
l'organisation nous sommes dans les
temps le compte à rebours est respectée
et bien sûr avec un sens de l'adaptation
réel est une très bonne coopération
entre le ministère et et l'ensemble des
organisateurs
bien entendu nous en rendrons compte
régulièrement devant la haute assemblée
je folio il avait quelques secondes
le ministre de ces de ces propos
rassurants mais je crois qu'il va
falloir qu'il y ait une véritable
mobilisation nationale pour faire de
telle sorte que ces grands événements
sportifs soit un élément très positif
pour le rayonnement de notre pays
merci à notre collègue jean louis masson
pour la réunion administrative des
sénateurs de figurants sont résiste donc
monsieur le ministre les usines de
moteurs et de bois
vitesse de trémery et de metz borny
avait été créé à l'époque pour compenser
la disparition de la sidérurgie et des
houillères
elles ont eu respectivement jusqu'à 6000
et 2900 emplois toutefois en raison de
diverses réorganisations et surtout de
la politique de remplacement du diesel
par les moteurs les criques elles n'en
n'ont plus que 3 1000 et 1300 en effet
même lorsque les moteurs électriques
sont assemblés en france la plupart de
leurs composants sont directement
importés de chine à cela s'ajoute le
transfert de plusieurs lignes de
production vers d'autres pays européens
le dernier transfert en date est celui
de la génération des moteurs turbo à
essence que le président hollande était
venu solennellement inaugurée à trémery
en 2017
quatre ans après il ne reste plus rien
toute la chaîne a été démontée et
transférée en pologne
monsieur le ministre est cela la
politique industrielle de la france
n'aurait-il pas été plus intelligent
d'organiser un recul moins brutale du
diesel
ensuite quand l'essentiel du parc
automobile aura été électrifiés l'etat
sera alors obligé de retrouver des
recettes fiscales en taxant à leur tour
les véhicules électriques
cela prouvera dans ces conditions que
leur compétitivité économique ege est
aujourd'hui complètement artificielle
puisque non seulement le rachat est
largement subventionnée mais en plus ces
véhicules ne supporte pour l'instant
aucune taxe sur le carburant
monsieur le ministre que comptez vous
faire pour éviter la disparition des
deux usines de trémery et de metz qui
ont été le fleuron de la conversion
industrielle de la lorraine dans les
années 70 et 80 pour vous répondre la
parole et mobilise délégués des comptes
publics olivier dussopt que je félicite
pour sa performance aujourd'hui
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs mais
c'est le sénateur masson votre question
permet d'abord de rappeler une empreinte
historique de l'industrie automobile en
moselle et vous avez évoqué tout
particulièrement le devenir du site de
trémery et de metz qui sont deux sites
qui appartiennent au groupe psa des ans
mais grosse telle antiste après sa
fusion avec fiat et chrysler le site de
trémery fabrique des moteurs diesel vous
l'avez dit celui de metz produit des
boîtes à vitesses automatiques et nous
savons que la conversion progressive du
parc automobile la sortie des énergies
fossiles sont plutôt de nature à
entraîner une baisse de cette activité
temps des moteurs diesel que des boîtes
à vitesses automatique puisque
l'essentiel des véhicules hybrides ou
électriques ont des boîtes à vitesses
automatiques et non pas manuel par des
mois pour la confusion dans le cadre du
plan de relance pour la filière
automobile
le groupe ps a désormais ses lentilles
ce après un certain nombre d'engagements
notamment pour reconvertir vers
l'électrification la totalité de ses
sites de production de chaînes de
traction des véhicules c'est dans ce
cadre qu'ont été annoncé deux
investissements
un investissement de 60 millions d'euros
sur le site de metz pour passer de la
production de boîtes à vitesses manuelle
à la production de boîtes à vitesses
automatique est un investissement de 140
millions d'euros sur le site de trémery
pour passer de la production de moteurs
diesel à des moteurs électriques dans ce
cadre là nous avons un objectif et c'est
ma collègue agnès pannier relâché
ministre délégué à l'industrie qui est
aussi particulièrement c'est faire en
sorte que les emplois des deux sites
sont les plus préservés possible et que
la transition vers les moteurs
électriques ou les boîtes à vitesses
automatique soit la plus protectrice
possible de l'emploi
nous y travaillons avec le groupe c'est
l'anti si nous serons évidemment rappelé
aux groupes les engagements qui ont été
pris même si aujourd'hui nous constatons
qu il les tient et qui met en oeuvre les
décisions qu'ils nous avaient annoncé
plus largement dans le cadre du plan de
relance nous avons la conviction que la
reconquête d'une forme de souveraineté
industrielle est une priorité majeure
nous devons faire en sorte de
relocaliser des activités nous devons
faire en sorte d'accompagner
l'innovation pour sécuriser et
stabiliser les emplois industriels et
donc producteurs de richesses sur notre
territoire
je me sens quelques secondes jouer
simplement vous dire monsieur le
ministre que dans le cadre de la
conversion industrielle
on a recréé cette wii fois moins
d'emplois que ce qu'on avait supprimé
mais maintenant on a déjà recouru contre
eux que retrouver très peu et maintenant
on fait disparaître ces emplois sans les
remplacer
moi ce que je mets en cause c'est
l'absence de de conscience du
gouvernement sur la nécessité de
compenser les emplois qu'on est en train
de supprimer par milliers et par
centaines
papa centaines et par milliers sur les
sites de trémery et demain c'est
vraiment terminé avec les questions au
gouvernement deux prochaines questions
en vous remerciant monsieur le premier
ministre et dames les messieurs les
ministres auront lieu le 24 mars 2021
mercredi prochains et on sera reprise à
16h40 pour l'examen de deux conventions
internationales la séance est suspendue
sur le sujet voilà pour cette séance que
vous avez pu suivre en intégralité et en
direct sur l'antenne de public sénat
on va tout de suite passé au débrief de
cette séance et rejoindre alexandre
poussard alexandre car vous êtes avec le
président du groupe
elle est réussie au sénat bruno
retailleau qui a posé une question au
gouvernement autour et bien de la crise
sanitaire
mais oui une question de bruno
retailleau pour revenir sur ce triste
anniversaire de la crise de lakovic 19
et bruno retailleau vous estimez que la
principale erreur du gouvernement c'est
d'avoir laissé trop seul nos aînés et
également les victimes de ce virus ya eu
un manque d'humanité de la part du
gouvernement
je pense que globalement je n'accuse pas
uniquement le gouvernement mais il ya eu
dans notre société un manque de prise en
charge notamment de nos aînés qu'on a
enfermé dans la solitude dans nos ehpad
et en les coupant notamment de leur
famille
on les a coupés leur raison de vivre
mais on a eu aussi dans les hôpitaux des
hommes et des femmes qui étaient plus
jeunes qui sont leur seul et je connais
malheureusement les familles qui se sont
adressés à moi et qui n'ont pas pu faire
ce rite de l'adieu et en ne pouvant pas
faire ce rite de l'adieu
il n'y a pas eu finalement un deuil qui
a été facile à faire et il ya un certain
nombre de voix qui sont en train de
s'élever et il ya d'ailleurs comment
réagit souliers mais aussi comme
beaucoup d'autres grands acteurs
catherine faut des gens qui lisent des
témoignages de ces familles vous les
trouverez facilement sur internet et
bien je pense que en cette date
anniversaire
je voulais que la voix de ces familles
la voix de ceux qui sont partis ne
restent pas me mettre ici au sénat alors
un autre sujet important aujourd'hui au
sénat c'est l'examen par la commission
des lois du sénat du projet loin de
lutte contre le séparatisme islamistes
il se trouve que la commission des lois
a rejeté un amendement auquel vous tenez
beaucoup qui interdit le pendre le port
de signes religieux par les accompagnant
de sorties scolaires pour étendre la
neutralité religieuse dans ses sorties
scolaires
est ce que vous allez remettre cette
mesure sur la table durant le débat dans
l'hémicycle dans deux semaines voilà
est-ce que vous allez revenir à la
charge
bien sûr puisque en réalité il ya eu peu
match nul puisque l'amendement a obtenu
15 pour et 15 contre voilà et dans ces
cas là il est il est donc comme on dit
rejeter donc nous re déposeront un
amendement qui reprendra d'ailleurs le
texte qui a été voté au sénat
il ya quelques mois sur les signes
ostentatoires je considère qu'on ne peut
pas parler du séparatisme
sans parler du voile qui est l'étendard
du séparatisme qui veut dire aux femmes
qu'elles sont d'un rang inférieur aux
sommes qui veut signifier aussi qu'on
sait par une partie de la population
française par rapport à la communauté
nationale
il faut avoir le courage de le dire et
je crois qu'il faut aussi avoir le
courage de le voter
est-ce que vous allez déposer un
amendement pourrait bien rebaptiser ce
texte avec le mot séparatisme islamistes
je vous confirme
vous êtes bien informé je pense que la
loi doit nommer les choses on doit pas
se cacher derrière le petit doigt si
nous voulons avoir une action efficace
ça commence par dire les choses il faut
avoir du bon sens et le titre ne veut
rien dire et je pense qu'il faut
beaucoup plus le cible et c'est ce que
nous ferons par la voie d'un amendement
dans l'hémicycle
en séance il rappelle que pour l'instant
ce texte s'appelle pour le respect des
principes de la république une dernière
question
bruno retailleau qui concerne la
présidentielle
l'un d'eux est votre collègue du parti
des républicains aurélien pradié qui
estime qu'une primaire de la droite
n'est pas nécessaire et qu'elle est bien
risquerait de réduire les républicains
au rang du nouveau parti anti
capitaliste qu'est ce que vous lui
répondais je crois qu'il est numéro 2 et
numéro 3 de ma famille politique et bien
j'attends de ces responsables qu'ils
suivent ce que nous avons voté en bureau
politique ou bien il y a un candidat
naturel
et alors là il n'y a pas besoin de
primaire mais s'il n'y a pas de candidat
naturel nous avons décidé et nous
l'avons voté à l'unanimité qu'il y
aurait des primaires et j'attends
justement cet effort de chacun arrêtons
de polémiquer et essayons d'appliquer
les décisions que nous prenons
c'est notre démocratie interne
d'ailleurs je ne réclame pas lé plus ni
moins que la démocratie la primaire
c'est la démocratie donner la
possibilité à nos électeurs à nos
sympathisants de choisir plutôt que de
faire des manoeuvres d'appareil
donc ça veut dire que justement la
direction du parti est déjà en train de
choisir non je dis que la direction du
parti est que christian jacob a voté
comme j'ai voté la résolution pour la
primaire s'il n'y a pas de candidat
naturel très bien merci beaucoup pour
une retailleau d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
c'est merci merci beaucoup à alexandre
un bruno retailleau donc plus que jamais
candidat à cette primaire si elle a bien
lieu on va continuer bien les réactions
salle des conférences
alexandre en revenant est bien sûr l'un
des temps forts de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement ce
n'était pas forcément attendu et c'était
lors de cet échange marquant entre
laurence rossignol
et ils le gardent des soeurs et dupond
moretti autour de la sphère georges tron
effectivement laurence rossignol
vous avez demandé durant cette séance la
révocation du maire de draveil georges
tron qui a été condamné à cinq ans de
prison pour viol et agression sexuelle
débat déjà un mot sur la forme vous êtes
émus du fait que ce soit le ministre de
la justice eric dupond moretti qui
viennent vous répondre car il a défendu
georges tron pour vous c'est une
provocation de la part du gouvernement
écoutez d'abord c'est la demande que
j'ai faite de révocation elle est prévue
dans le code des collectivités
territoriales le conseil des ministres
pdci de révoquer un maire quand son
comportement n'est pas compatibles avec
la dignité et l'autorité de la fonction
je considère que georges tron est en
prison
condamné pour viol et agression sexuelle
le conseil des ministres devrait être
évoquée je demande donc ceci au premier
ministre et quelle est ma surprise de
voir le garde des sceaux précédemment
avocat précédemment avocat de georges
tron me répondre sur le terrain de la
présomption d'innocence alors je pense
que le garde des sceaux aurait pu se
déporter comme on dit dans le monde de
la justice est à dire qu il aurait pu
dire écoutez moi je ne peux pas répondre
à cette question j'étais l'avocat de
l'accusé et du condamné et il a voulu
quand même répondre et en plus il m'a
répondu sur le terrain de la présomption
d'innocence alors que jean georges tron
est en prison et en fait il a été pareil
cet après midi qu'il a été pendant tout
le procès pendant tout le procès il a
traité les victimes de menteuse avec des
incidents de séance assez grave qui vont
au delà du droit de chacun à une défense
et aujourd'hui il revient me parler de
présomption d'innocence et dire en fait
les victimes sont des menteuses on ne
les crois pas encore
et pourtant georges tron c est bien il a
demandé un pourvoi en cassation est ce
qu'il ne faut pas attendre
et bien voilà l'issue de ce procès en
cassation avant de mettre pas de le
révoquer
écoutez je pense qu'on ne peut pas être
mère en prison voilà il a été incarcéré
à l'issue de l'audience
donc je crois que ce n'est pas
compatible d'être incarcéré et dette en
prison parce que c'est encore une façon
d'un part du gouvernement de dire qu' on
ne croit pas les victimes
en fait ce que je voulais dire dans
cette affaire c'est que on n'arrête pas
dire aux femmes parler parler parler
mais dès qu'elle parle on leur dit on ne
vous croit pas
et une fois de plus on dit aux victimes
de georges tron on ne vous croit pas
bien que l'auteur soit aujourd'hui en
prison c'était ça le message
le gouvernement doit dire comme tout le
monde à toutes les femmes qui parlent on
vous croit sur ce sujet c'est encore un
mauvais point qui est marqué par le
gouvernement sur le sujet des violences
sexuelles contre les femmes
je pense que ce quinquennat un problème
avec les hommes de pouvoir mis en cause
dans des affaires de violences sexuelles
à l'encontre des femmes je pense que ce
quinquennat pour ne pas le personnifier
pour parler d'une période d'une époque
aura révélé que en fait les femmes
victimes de violence ne sont toujours
pas cru et que les hommes de pouvoir
sont toujours eu cours
merci beaucoup aux laurence rossignol
pour votre réaction après cette séance
de questions d'actualité
un peu tendu merci merci beaucoup
alexandre et on a entendu en effet à
nouveau et bien la révolte de laurence
rossignol qui continue après cet échange
tendu très tendu tout à l'heure en
séance et on va continuer eh bien les
réactions salle des conférences puisque
vous êtes à présent avec patrick kanner
le président du groupe socialiste au
sénat qui lui aussi est l'occasion de ce
moment anniversaire a interpellé le
gouvernement autour de la crise
sanitaire
on va d'ailleurs en parler lors de ce
débrief inouïe à patrick kanner vous
avez interpellé le premier ministre jean
castex sur la méthode du gouvernement
dans la gestion de cette crise sanitaire
depuis un an et vous avez dénoncé une
gestion trop vertical depuis le le
conseil c'est de défense voilà depuis
l'elysée est ce que quand même sur ce
point le gouvernement n'a pas progressé
car et bien dans quelques heures
justement vous allez changer avec le
premier ministre tous les présidents de
groupes politiques du sénat avant le
tour de vis sanitaire qui va être
annoncé
qu'est ce que j'attends de cette
rencontre pas grand chose je vous le dis
très simplement le 28 janvier nous
étions rencontrés dans le même cadre 28
janvier donc il ya un mois et demi
maintenant
et monsieur castex nous laissait
entendre qu'il y aurait un confinement
pas assez de vaccins dont le très
mauvais chiffres des chiffres d'ailleurs
été moins mauvais que ceux qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
et puis patatras 24 ans plus tard
l'oracle emmanuel macron décide linverse
en disant mais on va donner encore une
dernière chance au pays moralité on a
perdu du temps c'est le maître du temps
perdu
aujourd'hui monsieur macro moi je je le
regrette parce que c'est quand même des
morts en plus c'est les personnes
malades
en plus c'est des médecins qui sont
débordés dans les hôpitaux donc une
situation quand même qui reste très
chaotique donc pour vous le gouvernement
a eu tort
finalement d'attendre le plus longtemps
possible avant de le confiner moi je ne
vous cache pas que si je l'avais dit le
28 janvier
monsieur castex en disant mais prenons
enfin le bon train
montons pas dans le train suivant parce
qu'il y aura de la casse et
malheureusement ça a été un choix qui je
crois est assumée mais dont il faudra un
jour rendre des comptes aux français
parce que d'autres pays avaient décidé
de fortement vacciner et de conflits
mais en même temps et nous on n'a fait
ni l'un ni l'autre
chacun le sait bien et aujourd'hui eh
bien on est on voit bien que c'est un on
à présent avoir devant nous un animal
sans tête qui courent dans tous les sens
et c'est ce que je crains pour notre
pays
alors des mesures sanitaires
supplémentaires devraient être annoncés
pour votre région les hauts de france
est ce que en tant qu'élu local déjà
est-ce que vous avez été consultés ce
que vous avez des informations et leur
confinement de votre région il est
inévitable écouter la télé si nous avons
une visioconférence demain avec le
préfet michel lalande je suppose qu'il
va nous préparer à cette décision qui
tombera demain soir dans la conférence
de presse de 18 heures comme tous les
jeudis soirs c'est la conférence des
mauvaises nouvelles
voilà je me prépare à cela je n'ai pas
été consulté nous sommes à peine
informés et jamais consulté et
d'ailleurs c'est le sens de ma question
que j'ai posée tout à l'heure monsieur
castex n'est pas vraiment répondu et c
est finalement tout se passe au conseil
de défense et au conseil de défense tout
se passe par le biais d' emmanuel macron
cette centralisation du pouvoir devient
insupportable en tout cas pour les
représentants de la nation et donc des
citoyens que nous sommes ici au
parlement
merci beaucoup patrick kanner d'avoir
répondu à mes questions is more merci
merci beaucoup à laax andré puis on va
avoir une dernière réaction salle à des
conférences toujours autour de la crise
sanitaire et alors que les
parlementaires les présidents des
groupes parlementaires vont s'entretenir
en visioconférence avec jean castex en
fin d'après-midi tout de suite et bien
hervé marseille le président du groupe
union centriste
ici au sénat il va est lui aussi un
participé à cette réunion avec les
autres présidents de groupe ainsi
qu'avec les également et bien les
présidents de groupe à l'assemblée ça
sera à 17 heures tout de suite
hervé marseille à votre micro ah oui
enfin marseille qu'est ce que vous
attendez de cette réunion entre tous les
présidents de groupes politiques du
sénat et le premier ministre est ce que
vous y croyez à cette réunion
comme toujours un moment sympathique des
changes l'accent chantant du premier
ministre et les chiffres qui vont être
exprimée par le ministre vers en voilà
et puis les différents scénarios sur la
table mais est-ce que vous allez avoir
de véritables informations
voilà perdons pas de temps on va passer
un moment sympathique des changes
et puis on va attendre que celui qui
commande des sites ayant président de la
république vous aussi finalement vous
dénoncer une gestion trop vertical dans
cette crise sanitaire depuis un an
c'est comme ça
depuis un an et j'allais dire que
l'année écoulée a renforcé j'allais dire
c'est hyper trophy exécutive l'alpha et
l'oméga de la politique français c'est à
l'elysée que ça se passe c'est là bas
que ça se décide
il n'y a aucune gestion collective alors
peut-être que c'est nécessaire en temps
de guerre comme on dit aujourd'hui
mais c'est comme ça que ça se passe donc
les changes qu'on aura ce soir sera
certainement sympathique mais limité
parlons de votre région alors à
marseille l'île de france puisque vous
avez élu des hauts-de-seine des mesures
supplémentaires pour l'ile-de-france
devrait être annoncé demain soir par le
premier ministre pourquoi avoir attendu
si longtemps avant de le confiner l'île
de france d'abord je ne sais pas si le
confinement
on le saura
ce soir ou demain j'en sais rien et puis
ensuite on peut pas il faut être juste
nous dans l'opposition on avait demandé
qu'on fasse de la différenciation
territoriales c'est ce qui a été fait
qu'on parle avec les élus même si c'est
un échange un peu unilatérale mais enfin
il ya ait un dialogue qui se fait avec
les élus donc on peut pas leur reprocher
et le président de la république a
essayé de tenir une ligne qui est
justement voulait éviter leur
confinement
donc on peut pas lui en vouloir et
d'ailleurs les français lui en sont
quelque part
reconnaissant donc et il a fait ce qu'il
a pu pour tenir malheureusement on voit
bien que les chiffres deviennent
préoccupants s'il faut reconfigurer
j'espère qu'on n'aura pas à re confiné
je pense que ça serait vraiment une
mauvaise chose pour l'ile-de-france qui
est pour la france parce que la région
capitale c'est quand même 20 % de la
richesse nationale
mais effectivement le poumon économique
du pays merci beaucoup mais hervé
marseille d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
et voilà tam pour cette série de
réactions après cette séance de
questions d'actualité
merci merci beaucoup alexandre on va
passer aux débrief de cette séance
en plateau avec valérie boyer bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice les
républicains des bouches du rhône et
membre de la commission des lois est
avec nous didier marie vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de seine-maritime et
vice président de la commission des
affaires européennes
un mot d'abord sur ce que l'on vient
d'entendre à travers et bien les prises
de paroles de patrick cannelle et puis
aussi celle d'hervé marseille on va
attendre que celui qui commande des
sites voilà qui est bien résumé didier
marie est ce que vous jugez aussi qu'il
ya eu trop de verticalité dans la
gestion de cette crise et que ça
continue c'est toujours ça ça continue à
être au conseil de défense sanitaire
mais comme viennent de le dire les
présidents de groupe
il n'y a pas de concertation on nous
informe de temps en temps et le
président a un public décide et tous les
jeudis soirs les mauvaises nouvelles
tombent
une fois qu'il a dit ce qu'il fallait
faire à ses ministres c'est ainsi que
cela fonctionne depuis le début de la
crise mais c'est aussi comme cela que ça
fonctionne depuis le début du
quinquennat sur toute une série d'autres
sujets donc
c'est dommageable surtout dans une
période de tensions extrêmes comme celle
que vit le pays
on aurait tout intérêt à rassembler
l'ensemble des forces politiques et des
forces de la société civile pour faire
corps et lutter contre ce drame que nous
connaissons vous êtes d'accord avec cela
notons tout de même qu'il va
s'entretenir en visio avec les élus
locaux d'ile-de-france des hauts de
france cet après midi vous n'y croyez
pas pour ce n'est pas une concertation
je suis d'accord à ce que vient de dire
mon collègue sur la méthode et sur le
fond ce qui se passe avec la crise
sanitaire s'est passé sur l'ensemble des
sujets et c'est vrai que le président de
la république passe par dessus la tête
du parlement en permanence s'il ya bien
un endroit et c'est ce que disait
patrick canon où on doit discuter de ça
c'est avec les représentants des
français c'est dans les deux chambres
que les français sont représentés et
nous sommes jusqu'à preuve du contraire
dans un régime parlementaire certes à
force domination présidentielle mais
notre régime est un régime parlementaire
donc on ne peut pas ignorer sans arrêt
le parlement ou ne pas tenir compte de
ce qu'il fait mais ce qu'emmanuel macron
fait avec le parlement il le fait avec
son gouvernement
il le fait même avec son premier
ministre et la séance à laquelle nous
venons d'assister ce week-end est
absolument dramatique
vous avez le premier ministre qui
dimanche soir essaye de rassurer sur un
vaccin est loin d'être assaini l'amdi
midi c'est le président de la république
lui même qui prend la parole pour dire
stop à ce que madame merkel venait de le
dire trois minutes avant donc on est
dans cette gestion qui est quand même
marqué par une forme de mépris des
manuels macron qui communique on peut
pas dire qu'il manque de communication
c'est comme le grand débat etc les
maires il a communiqué on a entendu que
lui c'était un grand monologue mais il
n'en est rien ressorti donc moi je ne
confonds pas communication information
et associations des élus et des
représentants des français parce que
c'est ça le sens du parlement
et je n'oublie pas non plus que c'est au
sénat que nous avons voté le fait qu'il
fallait
de temps en temps régionaliser un
certain nombre de décisions or qu'est-ce
qui se passe mon collègue viennent de le
dire nous sommes de temps en temps à
former notamment pour serrer la vis et
qu'on finit plus
mais quand on propose par exemple
l'ouverture des restaurants à midi comme
c'est le cas à marseille comme c'est le
cas pour l'ouest et c'est bien jamais
nous sommes associés jamais ces
décisions on arrive c'est fait consensus
oui mais l'autre exemple c'est la
convention citoyenne solar bana dont on
va parler prochainement au parlement qu
elles ont alors on réunit plusieurs
personnes pour discuter d'un sujet
essentiel pendant des semaines et des
semaines des préconisations sont faites
le président s'engage à les respecter
elle est proposée au parlement sans
filtre et au final le texte qui est
arrivé à l'assemblée nationale cette
semaine est un texte complètement
édulcorée et qui ne satisfera personne
ce cri très grave excusez moi sur la
convention ni la démocratie totalement
parce qu'on tire au sort et l'a tiré au
sort c'est vraiment l' inverse de la
méritocratie celle inverse de la
compétence c'est nier ce que ce que font
ces l'engagement des personnes et
saigner aussi les institutions et en
plus c'est mentir aux français parce que
ces personnes ne sont pas tirés au sort
par hasard donc c'est un tirage au sort
sélectionné donc on est vraiment là dans
la négation de la démocratie c'est
particulièrement grave nous sommes
également avec jean garrigues historien
et président du comité d'histoire
parlementaire jean garrigues qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire et bien ces
réactions unanimes de la part de
l'opposition et qui estime n'avoir
absolument pas leur place et bien dans
les décisions dans les textes
aujourd'hui pris par l'exécutif
écoutez je n'assistais depuis une
demi-heure une sorte de séance de
flagellation avec une convergence des
oppositions face au au pouvoir un
pouvoir dictatorial machiste etc etc
c'est intéressant c'est normal
d'ailleurs c'est le jeu de l'opposition
je pense que les critiques manque un
tout petit peu d'objectivité mais mais
il est vrai que à la faveur de cette
crise s'est produit une inflexion qui
pose question
du côté de du pouvoir exécutif et
notamment du pouvoir présidentiel
il est vrai que la décision de suspendre
la strazeele et cas suivants en
démontant ce qui avait été dit par le
premier ministre la veille pose question
sur le fonctionnement du couple exécutif
il ya beaucoup de questionnements qui
qui se pose à mon sens ils ne sont pas
réservées à la période de maquereaux
nien et les interlocuteurs qui sont là
le savent très bien
c'est l'aboutissement de toute une
histoire constitutionnelle et politique
de la vème république
il est vrai aussi qu'une période de
crise favorise ce type de resserrement
du pouvoir autour de l'exécutif que les
conseils de défense se sont se sont
multipliées qu' on pourrait souhaiter
que le parlement soit plus consultés je
pense que des efforts ont été faits
depuis quelques mois dans cette
perspective
mais il est vrai aussi que l'élection
présidentielle se profile et je
comprends que l'indulgence ce soit plus
à l'ordre du jour de la part de
l'opposition de gauche comme de
l'opposition de droite
ils ont raison ils jouent ce jeu mais
souffrez qu'un observateur comme moi
prennent un tout petit peu de distance
par rapport aux critiques qui sont
faites parce qu'elle me semble-t-il à un
tout petit peu je dirais parfois
caricaturales un tout petit peu
excessive mais il ya un fond de frais je
le répète c'est incontestable pour les
amateurs les admirateurs les les fans de
l'histoire parlementaire comme moi on
est aujourd'hui un peu sur sa faim et on
aimerait qu'il y ait un rééquilibrage
des pouvoirs sous la vème république
oui voilà donc sur la méthode il a aussi
été question de fond un le fond des
problèmes de la crise anitea lors de
cette séance on va tout de suite
rejoindre steve jourdain puisque et bien
la science est d'ailleurs ouverte et
bien sûr une question d'eliane assassi
la présidente du groupe communiste à
jean castex là encore sur la crise
sanitaire et sur l'état
de l'hôpital 8ème vous en parliez tout à
l'heure l'un des moments forts de cette
séance était évidemment et bien cette
passe d'armes en quelque sorte entre
jean castex et président de roubles 3
présidents de groupes qui ont demandé et
bien au gouvernement à quels
enseignements avaient été tirés eh bien
depuis un an un an et le début du tout
premier confinement à gauche
la communiste eliane assassi a demandé
ce que le gouvernement avait fait très
concrètement en matière de capacités
hospitalières écoutez la quel choix
allez vous effectuer pour ouvrir en
urgence dans les jours à venir des lits
de réanimation et allez vous prendre des
dispositions pour sortir les vaccins de
la logique du marché
en levant les brevets et pour accélérer
considérablement la réalisation et la
production d'un vaccin français pas
facile hein pas facile de former des
médecins réanimateurs dans un délai
aussi court c'est ce qui a répondu eh
bien jean castex pour autant bien le
gouvernement n'est pas resté les bras
croisés pendant un an jean castex
inventé bien les mérites du ségur de la
santé écoutez le quels enseignements tir
en août cette crise n'aurait pu attendre
la fin de la crise pour le faire on n'a
pas fait ça s'appelle le ségur de la
santé ça s'appelle le set
9 y'a rien dedans 9 milliards et demi
d'euros comment pouvez-vous dire y'a
rien dedans je viens d'annoncer 19
milliards pour le volet investissement
madame la présidente et c'est
extrêmement important moi qui ai connu
et j'en suis fière les plan hôpital 2007
et hôpital 2012
c'est 50% de plus que ces deux plans
réuni que vous allez que nous allons que
la nation va engager au bénéfice du
service de santé
pas sûre que hélène eliane assassi et la
gauche de l'hémicycle est était vraiment
convaincu par cette réponse tam et oui
on a entendu fusée à gauche de
l'hémicycle cette phrase n'y a rien
dedans à propos du ségur de la santé 9
milliards et demi tout de même pourquoi
est-ce que vous jugez que c'est à ce
point là insuffisant à didier mario joie
l'était en tant qu'élus nous sommes en
contact avec les personnels soignants de
nos hôpitaux dans nos territoires
que ce soit les médecins que ce soit les
personnels soignants que ce soit les
aides soignantes que ce soit toutes
celles et ceux qui contribuent à lutter
contre la crise que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et il considère que le
compte n'y est pas le compte n'y est pas
à titre personnel parce que ce sont pas
les quelques dizaines d'euros qui leur
ont été attribuées sous forme de primes
aux augmentations de salaire à venir
pour certains d'entre eux qui les
satisfont et puis surtout le compte n'y
est pas y compris dans les moyens mis à
disposition pour mener la bataille
moi je suis intervenu encore la semaine
dernière auprès de l' agence régionale
de santé pour demander des renforts en
hommes l'effectif pour faire que les
services puissent répondre à la demande
des malades tout simplement
valérie boyer on ne forme pas des
médecins en quelques mois a également
répondu
texte à propos des critiques faites sur
le manque de lits de réanimation
aujourd'hui une évidence
en revanche il est possible de créer des
équipes mobiles il est possible de
mobiliser des médecins il est possible
de fermer des ibode des infirmiers
anesthésistes il est possible de
rappeler des médecins à la retraite par
exemple où il est possible de mobiliser
des professions de santé qui par
ailleurs sont sont déjà extrêmement bien
formés et pour les formes et juste oco
vide juste à la surveillance des malades
du cobp id
on ne demande pas de forme et d'un coût
de claquements de doigts des médecins
réanimateurs en 12 ans ne faut pas
répondre à côté de la question
ces choses-là on sait les faire et les
professionnels de santé ne demande que
ça c'est ça qu'on demande et tout à
l'heure ce permettez je réponds à la
fois monsieur garrigues et à cette
question je pense que nous ne sommes pas
dans la caricature j'aimerais bien
d'ailleurs avoir un débat sur justement
sur les institutions et sur la
caricature c'est pas la caricature c'est
le constat moi c'est mon troisième
mandat de parlementaire et j'ai vu qu'il
y avait une différence de traitement du
parlement de la de même de la même façon
lorsque nous faisons des propositions
jamais elles ne sont acceptés et c'est
pas simplement dans le domaine de la
santé
c'est dans tous les domaines et je n'ai
pas vu de 2007 à 2012
je ne les ai pas vus de 2012 à 2017 avec
la même intensité et ça c'est une
réalité
on va faire répondre jean garrigues mais
tout de suite on va rejoindre un autre
jeanjean massiet pour et bien revenir
sur cette séance et qu'est-ce qui a
marqué les internautes de twitch avec
lesquels et bien tu échanges depuis
maintenant quasiment deux heures autour
de cette science qu'est ce qu'ils ont
pensé de cette séance en est bien un
coup de tam c'était une séance très
politique aujourd'hui on a vu les
présidents de groupes qui ont pris qui
ont pris le devant de la scène notamment
l'intervention de patrick kanner qui a
été très incisif sur la méthode
l'utilisation à rallonge du conseil de
défense toujours aussi critiqué et
l'opacité autour des avis du conseil
scientifique qui sont pas publiés attend
la réponse de jean castex qui a montré
patte blanche en disant mais tout va
bien le gouvernement est parfaitement
transparent et prend les décisions qui
s'imposent au bon moment et de la bonne
manière
sa part
vraiment convaincu les internautes qui
sont plutôt du côté des sénateurs en
critiquant le manque de transparence du
gouvernement
il y avait aussi la question du
président retailleau du président du
groupe l'est républicain
question un peu plus philosophique qui
demandait voilà après un an
l'anniversaire après un an de coheed
quant à quelles sont les leçons qui en
sont tirées par jean castex jean castex
à tâcher de répondre avec une note
d'espoir nous vaincrons le virus nous
finirons par la vaincre
là aussi je t'avoue que les internautes
bompas super convaincu c'est vrai que ça
fait un an qu'on est dans cette panade
on avait un peu du mal à y voir à voir
le bout du tunnel
je suis pas sûr que jean castex et
réussi à convaincre m'enfin pour les
choses avancent et enfin une question
assez intéressante du sénateur de la
haye à propos du rapport de jean arthuis
sur la tête du coc vide que faire de
cette dette
le gouvernement tout comme jean arthuis
et comme le sénateur de la est exclu une
annulation de la dette qu'ovide pour
autant ça je te cache pas que les
internautes
là il s'intéresse un peu à ce sujet là
quand s comment est-ce qu'on va payer
cette dette covit comment est-ce qu'on
va payer tout cet argent la question
d'annulation de la dette est plutôt
populaire sur internet
on verra la suite des discussions sur ce
sujet ah oui la question de la dette et
le quoi qu'il en coûte qui ont été
également abordés lors de cette séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
merci beaucoup j'en ai à la semaine
prochaine on va parler à présent d'un
autre thème on va parler du projet de
loi séparatisme en tout cas ces cartes
ainsi que votre groupe voudrait le
rebaptiser valérie boyer et on va
revenir et bien sûr l'examen en
commission de ce texte avec vous
alexandre car vous êtes avec stéphane
pieds noirs qui est et bien rapporteur
pour la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation de ce texte et il avait un
certain nombre de ces amendements passé
aujourd'hui
effectivement plusieurs amendements que
vous avez déposé stéphane pieds noirs
ont été votées dans ce projet de loi de
lutte contre le séparatisme et notamment
un amendement qui supprimait une mesure
du gouvernement visant à durcir et bien
les conditions d'enseignement à domicile
l'ambition du gouvernement c'est de
protéger certains enfants de
l'endoctrinement à domicile et vous avez
jugé que c'était une mesure est une
mesure liberticide
oui absolument en a en commission hier
après-midi changer le texte qui nous a
été proposé par l'assemblée nationale 2
en prenant de l'assemblée nationale
qu'ils aient un changement de régime sur
l'instruction en famille on passait
d'une régime déclaratif un régime
d'autorisation
qui est une forme de suspicion
généralisée à l'encontre des familles
qui pratiquent les lèvres depuis
plusieurs années une manière tout à fait
régulière et avec un un
approfondissement des dés la pédagogique
et qu'elle met en oeuvre
donc on a on a changé absolument ça pour
conserver cette liberté dans cette
instruction à domicile qui fait partie
d'une des voies d'instruction dans notre
pays qui est une liberté reconnu et
protégé par notre constitution
donc on a souhaité revenir à ce projet
de principes de déclaration pour
protéger cette liberté alors vous avez
travaillé également sur la laïcité à
l'université vous avez fait voter des
amendements au texte pour renforcer la
laïcité à l'université en quoi ça va
consister les amendements vous avez fait
voter alors d'abord il faut rappeler que
ce texte à l'origine visait à lutter
contre le séparatisme islamisme et que
l'école d'une manière générale et le
sport sont des cibles et des entrées
privilégiées
or le texte qui nous a été proposée ne
répond pas aux enjeux majeurs de ce
séparatisme et à l'ampleur du phénomène
donc on a souhaité consolider à la fois
sur l'école publique mais aussi sur
l'université parce que on constate des
dérives des dérives ont été constatées
mais ça reste évidemment très marginale
mais il vaut mieux prévenir que guérir
et en tout cas avoir des dispositions
par exemple qui interdisent de
s'approprier des salles d'enseignement
pour y faire des prières il faut se
prémunir contre des comportements qui
sont de nature par un prosélytisme ou
une propagande à perturber des activités
de recherche ou d'enseignement à
l'intérieur des campus c'est sont des
amendements qui ont été votés hier en
commission mais c'est une réalité
le fait qu'il y ait des des activités
religieuses dans les salles de cours oui
encore une fois c'est extrêmement
marginale mais on n'est pas en train de
dire que l'université est totalement à
part dans la société est un terreau
extrêmement fertile ça fait partie de la
société il y à des dérives au sein du
campus universitaire c'est exceptionnel
c'est si le nesc néanmoins il faut il
faut s'y attaquer et prendre d'ailleurs
des dispositions dans la loi qui vont
permettre aux universités de décrire des
règlements intérieurs qui auront une
base juridique beaucoup plus solide
merci beaucoup stéphane pieds noirs de
nous avoir expliqué toutes les
modifications que vous avez apporté à ce
projet de loi de lutte contre le
séparatisme
merci beaucoup alexandrins plusieurs
choses dans cette interview jean
garrigues je voudrais d'abord vous faire
intervenir sur ce dont parlait et bien à
la fin stéphane pieds noirs sur ces
dérives de séparatisme à l'université
c'est un sujet qui a largement été dans
le débat ces dernières semaines est ce
que pour vous il ya réellement
aujourd'hui une difficulté supérieur à
l'université sur un certain nombre de
sujets d'enseignement par exemple liés à
cette question du séparatisme
j'aurais d'abord dire que
personnellement ça n'engage que moi mais
je préfère l'expression de principes
républicains
plutôt que celle de séparatisme non pas
que le séparatisme n'existe pas et y
compris et d'abord le séparatisme venant
de l'islamisme tenir là l'intégrisme
musulman né mais parce que je pense que
dans la société qui est la nôtre les
rues petit vite et la société qui est la
nôtre
le terme de renforcement des principes
républicains de rappel au principe
républicain me semble être le plus
adéquat pour ce qui concerne
l'université effectivement je suis
universitaire et le sénateur pieds-noirs
le raison de dire que il s'agit là d'un
phénomène qui reste très marginal il
faut les il faut le reconnaître il y a
deux de manière très concrète de plus en
plus de deux jeunes filles dont une
femme qui porte le voile dans nos
universités
mais les manifestations de prosélytisme
musulman ou religieux dans en général
sont très très très minoritaire dans le
monde universitaire il faut le
reconnaître
en revanche ce qu'on a appelé l'islamo
gauchisme dont aucun à une sorte de
proximité de quelques groupements
d'extrême gauche avec les idées
extrémistes de l'islam
ça peut exister mais c'est un chant très
politique et qui est réservé à quelques
associations et quelques minorité
d'étudiants e syndiqués je le répète
pour l'instant le problème ne me semble
pas majeur à à l'université je ne dis
pas qu'il ne faille pas légiférer là
dessus
moi je ne fais pas partie de ceux qui
qui repousse cette question d'un trait
de plume
mais en revanche je le répète pour
l'instant on n'est pas encore dans une
véritable un véritable questionnement de
société à l'université
valérie boyer la question du port du
voile a été largement évoquée ce matin
en commission plusieurs amendements ont
donc été finalement rejetée par la
commission celui sur l'interdiction du
voile pour les accompagnatrices de
sorties scolaires on en a parlé avec
bruno retailleau et puis aussi le vôtre
sur l'interdiction du voile pour les
mineurs vous allez leur déposer dans
dans l'hémicycle en séance en oui bien
sûr je vais leur déposer sur le premier
je pense que il ya plusieurs façons
d'aborder les choses pour les
accompagnatrices scolaire c'est soit
considéré que l'école est aussi hors les
murs et à ce moment-là appliquer le même
règlement en tout cas moi je plaide et
pour ça et ça a failli passer mais bon
je plaidais pour que aua cascades mais
je je je plaidais je leur déposerait
pour que soient appliqués pour les
sorties scolaires puisque c'est l'école
hors des murs les mêmes règles pour que
ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de l'école
ça c'est le premier point sur le
voilement des fillettes je pense que
c'est un signal important qui va au delà
de d'une question de religion ou de
provocation ou identitaire c'est un
problème de maltraitance de l'enfance
parce qu'on apprend à séparer les filles
des garçons et surtout les filles
pudique des chiens pudique et c'est pas
un message républicain c'est pas un
message de ces pas un message d'union
nationale et c'est pas un message qui va
avec les liberté l'égalité et la
fraternité
donc ça c'est vraiment ce sont des
choses qui sont importantes et je j'ai
beaucoup de difficulté à entendre le
fait qu'on me dise le conseil d'état va
leur jeter le conseil constitutionnel
aussi etc
dont acte qui le rejette mais moi ce que
j'aimerais beaucoup c'est connaître les
arguments justement si ce type
d'amendements été votée rejeté de ses
instances pour qu'on ne le vote pas
parce que c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne moi je ne me substitue pas à
à ses instances et je comprends très
bien que des choses soient rejetés alors
qu'elles sont votées mais ce qui est
très intéressant c'est de lire leurs
arguments et donc j'attends avec
impatience si ces arguments sont vos si
celle-ci ces amendements sont votés et
qu'ensuite ils sont rejetés par le
conseil cautionnait lh2
connaître les arguments du conseil
constitutionnel une dernière réaction
didier marie l'ensemble du débat sur le
voile et bien il a été écarté à
l'assemblée nationale où elle est vraie
mais majoritaires mais là on sent bien
que le débat il va avoir lieu une fois
de plus dans l'air même le voulait
notamment de la majorité sénatoriale
si vous permettez je crois qu'on ne peut
pas résumer ce texte la seule question
du voile sur laquelle je vais revenir
dans un examen permet tait mais ce texte
est très loin des ambitions qui avait
été affichée par le président de la
république lors de son fameux discours
aux mureaux il nous avait dit l'ordre et
la promesse républicaine
on a une partie de l'ordre on n'a rien
de la promesse la promesse c'était
qu'est ce que l'on fait sur
l'intégration qu'est ce que l'on fait
sur l'école républicaine qu'est ce que
l'on fait sur l'accès au logement qu'est
ce que l'on fait contre la lutte sur les
discriminations rien de tout ça dans le
texte
oui par contre ce texte est aussi un
texte de stigmatisation un texte
défiance défiance à l'égard des
associations on remet en cause une
partie de la loi 1901 défiance à l'égard
des cultes l'état voulant s'immiscer
dans l'organisation véhicule a fait
notre défiance à l'égard des médias
c'est un texte qui pose toute une série
problème pour ce qui concerne le voile
si vous permettez wintour
moi je considère qu'aujourd'hui il est
préférable qu'une maman voilée viennent
à l'école parce qu'elle fait un pas vers
la république en faisant cela et que ses
enfants soient scolarisés dans l'école
publique laïque plutôt qu'elle là il est
scolarisé
ensuite parce qu'elle a été rejetée dans
une école confessionnelle
merci merci d'être un parlementaire
célèbre henri dominique lacordaire qui
disait entre le faible et le fort c'est
la loi qui protège la liberté qui
opprime pour protéger la république et
pour protéger l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes je pense que nous avons
besoin d'un texte mais bien merci
valérie boyer merci didier marie
merci beaucoup jean garrigues d'avoir
été avec nous en visio pour donner vos
éclairages lors de ceux des primes des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
tout de suite place à l'audition de la
ministre
[Musique]